[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
um
[Music]
ah
[Music]
uh
uh
[Music]
well
[Music]
ah
[Music]
uh
oh
[Music]
please
[Music]
um
incredible performance
i love this guy back to back i'll see
you need oh
my god
give it up for your champion
is this not some good ass tekken ladies
and gentlemen
welcome everyone to the tekken online
challenge for south africa i'm rip here
with mark man i can't believe we're
doing south africa this this is awesome
you know uh tekken online challenge it's
a global thing second world tour you
know we're going all over the place this
time focusing on the wonderful community
of south africa how are you feeling rip
i feel great i mean honestly just saying
the words like tekken online challenge
south africa those are words i never
expected to say in my life you know of
course myself born in south africa you
know this is this is kind of special
it's very interesting to see what the
community out there is going to have to
offer
oh yeah looking forward to there's a a
lot of names you know we're trying to
whittle down our top eight we're going
into some of the losers qualifiers and
before we get into the matches uh i'm
kind of excited to see you know the type
of gameplay you know recently we did the
west africa event and we saw a lot of
the talent out there we've been hitting
and doing more regions than we've done
in the past for tekken online challenges
so again an exciting time for us to
again bring different spotlight to
different regions and different players
and communities
exactly and like honestly guys you know
this new regions like around the world
that we're seeing for the first time uh
it's just the craziest thing like
pakistan came out of nowhere like could
south africa be the next pakistan you
know we'll we'll find out i guess we
will definitely find out but before i
want to give a big shout out to our
friends over at astro the official
headset and mix amp of the tekken online
challenge thank you for always
supporting tekken and again excited to
get into the matches
most definitely of course guys we
already had started this tournament
earlier so we're wheeling it down as
mark said to the top eight uh so we
could probably see a couple of qualifier
matches before we get there plus the top
rate itself
oh yeah
let's actually take a look at the
current leaderboard for south africa for
the tekken online challenge and of
course the tekken world tour as you can
see there are a number of players that
already have been participating in dojo
events in the region you see droopy at
the top here you see uh i don't know how
to pronounce it it's d-a-x-a
all right that makes sense for me and
then um yeah again rounding out the top
five uh a lot of players but again just
because uh
i think because of the nature of the
event and how many points you get from
these master events whoever wins today
is probably going to be in first place
more than likely actually they will 100
percent
pretty much guaranteed right so of
course these are just like the first
round matches i guess for the
for the qualifiers for the series and
then we still have the regional finals
coming up later right so a couple of
opportunities for the players here to
score some points
mostly 90 players close to 90 players
have participated throughout today's
event so far and again we're getting
closer and closer to our top eight as we
uh jump into those matches i'm super
excited yeah i'm really excited to see
what characters we see like you know i
know there's a little twitter teaser
clip that showed some of the players i
saw like a gin player that was pretty
good i saw steve fox player that was
pretty good uh so it's always exciting
you know to find out what the region's
gonna offer what their big characters
are because even when we look at like
tearless online uh you know it varies
region by region right so a lot of times
those cheerleaders are determined by the
players and what characters they use
oh yeah
again looking forward to that uh
any particular characters you think
would be popular to the region
because you know it's different
everywhere it's different everywhere
yeah you know that's a very interesting
question i think that
uh i would love to see some of the dlc
characters represented uh you know
because i feel like whatever region
picks up the dlc and like really sticks
with it early it's kind of a mark like
these guys are like trying to win you
know and then on the other hand you have
regions that are like we're character
loyalists you know this is my character
i'm sticking with it forever uh so if
that's the case and i think we're
probably going to see like i mentioned
steve and jen i think those are going to
be characters that we use yeah
tekken has been popular uh especially in
south africa for quite some time now
there's been a competitive community you
know they're always pushing content out
on twitter you know obviously got the
attention of everybody leading into this
year that's why this is one of the
reasons that we're focusing on for the
tekken online challenge um i'm curious
to see kind of like what you mentioned
whether or not people will be embracing
uh not only the guest characters but
also the newer dlc uh one of the hot
topics lately in terms of dlc is a lot
of top players have been putting
together their thoughts on on the on the
cast and tier list and we see lydia at
the top more often than not nowadays
yeah that's kind of odd to me honestly
like it is odd it is god because
she she didn't get better since her her
launch she got a little bit adjusted
right but i guess with everyone else's
adjustment more and more players are
starting to figure out that she is
definitely up there on the tears you
know we've seen it results wise too
right we saw with certain events like
evo japan a lot of uh bigger dojo events
and also online events that lydia was
definitely up there yeah i think the
thing about lydia currently is that she
still has some strings which are like i
always forget the name of this thing
it's like
political storm is that the name of it
one plus two yes politicians yes
i feel like it's just so abusable you
know like even though there's a there's
a guy frame hit confirmable yeah yeah
it's just too good as is right and like
those kind of tools in tekken especially
forward advancing moves in any fighting
game
are always gonna be good especially when
they're that safe so that's probably one
thing's carrying her up there like i
think i've seen other people talk about
her down back three uh being really good
but i've always thought that that move
is it's good for sure but not like it's
gonna say leroy's or paul's even you
know so oh yeah i definitely agree yeah
it's an interesting strategy and like if
you play the character uh you realize
quickly she doesn't really have a lot of
options like to launch you right like
she doesn't have
like i mean she has to go for like her
hop kick and hopkins punishable you know
so
we will see oh and spaghetti dude is
this the spaghetti that spag was talking
about on twitter that one time
it is crazy because you know smack has
beef with two different people he has
beef with the spaghetti and he has beef
with the rip i don't think he's got beef
with me oh well well if he doesn't have
beef if he doesn't have beef it's not
really spaghetti then
that's true i just wanted to say that
i'm sorry
but he's going up against got hurt your
voice get all excited
i got super excited but uh that should
be that should be exciting but um kind
of going back to what you were talking
about with lydia she she doesn't have
like you know the best launchers as you
said it comes in at certain frames but
she does have an answer for everything
on paper she has like a 11 a 12 or 13 or
14. framework standing punish
right a 15 no great yeah she's she's
great in a lot of departments but uh
it's very curious to see her at the top
the other character lately that has been
making a lot of waves is actually fang
wei you know and his adjustments you
know were really good at justice because
it just gave bonus damage to everything
he was already gonna do essentially yes
like all these pokes that you couldn't
do anyway they're all a little bit
better and now you're seeing like
everyone who had a little bit of trouble
fighting for now they have actual
trouble with playing they're like hmm
and the down back three counter chains
that's huge you know for the longest
time um i i've always believed like when
a tekken character or a character forces
you to play a certain way or to be
cognizant of certain things going into
the matchup then they have an inherent
advantage just out the gate right for
example fenway his reverse tempo step
kind of changes things for a lot of uh
opponents and how they would approach
the matchup uh very much in the same way
like when akuma has meter you do not
want to get hit right
so it's kind of like these things that
kind of force you to play a certain way
that inherently it's just like a natural
thing it forces the matchup to to run a
certain way that you can't get away with
certain things and again having that
advantage especially in tournament
settings in a two out of three you have
to be ready for that kind of stuff yeah
anyways predictions are up if you guys
are in the twitch chat uh kind of let us
know who you think is gonna win there
are uh points channel points that are uh
can be wagered i'm thinking about uh
doubling down here i don't know i like
spaghetti but i'm more of a lasagna guy
i'm leaning towards spaghetti i'm
thinking about it like in terms of all
right look from rip there came a
spaghetti rib maybe from a spaghetti rip
they became a spaghetti so technically
this is like my bloodline you know it's
like your pseudo your pseudo next of kin
right
right maybe uh dude who knows but i'm
excited to see it uh i think spaghetti
the reason that was even brought up
before is because spaghetti did do well
uh in a previous tournament so i i think
that this is definitely a player to keep
an eye on here uh in this tournament
today yeah i'm gonna actually take a
look at the bracket uh looks like we are
gonna be getting ready to go into the
matchup a couple of big names for the
region already in the tournament so
frost is uh still battling i believe in
the loser side of his pool as they go
through x-star also in the tournament as
well that's just in pool number one oh
it's lydia so hey they are embracing
some of the newer characters and lydia
versus jack this should be an
interesting matchup because jack one of
those characters he can get away with a
lot of different things if you are not
on point with punishes so this this
should be an interesting match up as we
go into this
man look at the icon down there or
africa that is so cool
i've never noticed i've never seen the
color the color right so you're seeing
uh europe which is i think yellow right
right is it yellow yes
and then and then there's blue for for
asia or in certain parts of asia or
korea and japan
and triggering north america's green
four i think it's blue for europe and
yellow for asia man oh my god i gotta
make stuff
it was nice
oh a nice duck ready for that four
uh that fourth string here we go pushing
towards the wall boom
back to pressure at the wall now
and this is a loser's qualifier to get
into top eight guys
yeah very very important
still in pools
nice block there gets the punish
oh here we go here's the pressure
very different style from what i see
with the lydia so if it goes for the
political sword nice block there on the
down back too but no punish damn back to
i think is one of the best slow tools
i've seen in the game
she gets low
very low yeah it's somewhat like dragon
i was down to right
it actually has more evasive uh more of
an evasive uh hurt box from what i've
seen didn't kill oh
slow
first round of the day all right i like
where we're starting
yeah they're coming out very aggressive
too
[Music]
yeah see that that use of that ford ford
ii just that hit itself same thing with
the running one it complements the rest
of her attacks similar to like oh my god
there's the downback three the lows once
you start gets forced to start blocking
and start moving around that's when she
starts pulling out moves like the
political storm that forward plus two
rush
but again back to the wall gotta be
careful
man can you imagine if that wall splat
two that move right great
then people would be really talking
about her yeah
but rage mode for onyx class an
opportunity to make a comeback right now
the down back three the
all i know is political storm and red
tape
sounds like a pr uh a press conference
waiting to happen
oh they trade blows dude the trades are
crazy political storm though
and the throw again no break wall splat
this time yep angle is good
spaghetti hold it on here
but you can see he immediately wants to
take the advantage right like the
offensive pressure he starts off with
his jab all this leads a lot of single
jab into
follow-ups yeah and one of the things
too is like with lydia her hockey is so
weird it has like an instant crush
window right it's like super crazy
but it's one of those things like you
have to test your opponent because she
really doesn't have that many bids that
are that threatening
she has the
oh my god the three two but the three
two is like what 17 frames
uh yeah i think so
but boy final round game one what the
high and i was talking about right
there's been a lot of single jab
pressure out of spaghetti onyx though
doesn't get the dash on the combo for no
wall carry
tape follow up the sidestep attack into
the jackhammer
oh oh oh oh
could have gotten oh more off that trade
but still chopping away the ankles right
now blocked it no launch and doesn't
matter jackhammer going to close out
game one for onyx
boy
that was back and forth yeah nice
opening match that we've seen so far
could have gone either way uh
that jack play was clean it it did the
job very solid again this is a loser's
match to qualify on the loser side of
our top eight so very very important
lots on the line points are on the line
of course
and i see you guys in the chat
rooting all the people that you guys bet
your points on uh but that was very
close you know and really it was the
call out that final round that sealed
the deal right there's a lot of jab
pressure from spaghetti uh you saw onyx
duck immediately started around like you
can throw a jab boom there it is while
standing one full launcher and you know
anytime in the final round situation the
opponent immediately gets a launch at
the start of the round it's really
demoralizing right
one of the things i noticed
i was gonna say one of the things i
noticed in that opening matchup is at
the at the very start of the match uh
spaghetti was able to sidestep that
forward forward one so obviously having
that confidence in in that move in in
the matchup i guess but every other ford
ford one from there he was either
blocked or it hit it hit a lot
especially towards the very end so i
think uh obviously there there's uh some
learnings there from that first match is
to kind of watch out for that pattern
because there was a lot of that
jackhammer used in the match up
especially at the very end while
standing four on hit into four four to
one again you got to make sure that
you're you're not trying to move because
it hit every single time he's gonna have
to kind of be more aware of that yeah
and jackhammer was one of those moves
that was buffed again right like going
back to tekken 7 season 1 they removed
the tracking on it so that like you
could step it much easier but then this
latest patch they actually gave it a
little bit of tracking back so i've
heard that it's not as good as it used
to be back in the day so it's kind of
this middle ground from season one and
uh where it is nerfed afterwards so uh
very interesting to see that you can
still step it lydia still has the size
of ability we saw right from the get-go
but
uh right now you know you gotta still be
cautious about especially on hit like
you mentioned after the wall standing
four because that's obviously what cost
him the game there
yep
all right as we get in this is gonna be
it
could be a
could be a short match depends if uh
onix is able to close it out here but
let's see if spaghetti can answer back
sticking to lydia and we're going to the
geometric plane
so you know this is one thing you know
i'm going to say this very early on uh
with these new regions that we're
including in the tekken online challenge
uh there's always this always happens
and this is outside of you know the the
main competition
i've always seen people accidentally
pick
um custom outfits instead of sticking to
the the default ones i wonder if we're
going to see one of those
now these guys give us an extra break
yeah they're they see they're pro so far
all right let's see planner
whoa wait wait wait wait wait
patriot knuckle at the out the gate
that would have been crazy if it hit
like what would have been the read
yeah well
yeah
if it hit
but there's that down 4-2 able to close
out the round onyx continuing that
momentum from the last
match he's a juggernaut
all right here we go
and again just very very clean play
waiting to get in range
and
spaghetti is
is taking a lot of liberties here using
a lot of that down back three
the thing is with that move even though
it's a great move don't get me wrong you
have to get in the right range but it's
forcing him to play up close and i think
that's where the strength of onyx's jab
is coming into play
yeah the thing is spaghetti done really
good job doing a dash into the directory
so he was always getting the clean head
uh the problem is i mean not even a
problem one of the other good things is
that onyx hasn't lost it yet right like
he's got one block on it and has not
lost it but right now chopping away rage
mode working out in favor of these pokes
damn he really wants that for one plus
two good block there on the range drive
debug
the jabs they're working so well five
out of range
no time
almost almost and that was a good duck
there right because he recognized like
you're not gonna do a big mid
so you want that down by three to close
it out of time not gonna get it onyx set
point right now to make it into top
eight
yeah one more round can do it wow dunked
right underneath that
nice he's not falling for it i would
start going in with more lows
yeah definitely
great side step
nice combo here wow
ducks the running one here comes the
combo
yeah this is gonna hurt big
time hmm
you have one more guess
at the wall
rage drive
into the oh my god
oh perry
what a read
he knew he knew and onyx taking a
three-round straight
very very convincing there and
unfortunately for spaghetti out of the
tournament at ninth place
yeah worth the risk there to go for that
low prairie still had two rounds to play
with afterwards right so very nicely
done onix moves on into the top eight of
this tournament uh unfortunately that
does end spaghetti one going out in
ninth year uh but yeah we are just
getting started here for this stream at
least right we still got a lot more
action coming away we still have i
believe another match or two to another
couple probably to get into this top
eight and round out the full top eight
bracket yeah actually i'm gonna actually
take a look at the brackets right now to
see if we're even
at our top eight uh obviously with audix
that that's a qualification into the top
eight uh let's see where we're at at the
rest of the brackets we looks like we do
have some players already in there at
least on the winner's side and from what
i'm looking we have uh callum uh bukes
uh big daddy mike uh droopy
and dvk so far
nice so we do have some players already
in the winter side of our top eight
these are all gonna be losers qualifiers
uh going into our top eight so again
lots on the line the difference between
being out of the tournament at ninth and
getting some nice points for uh top
eight which again when we're looking at
the leaderboard and you guys can see it
on the ticker at the bottom of the
screen these points are important
especially when it comes to qualify for
the regional finals later uh i believe
in december
or throughout throughout december and
the rest of the year
exactly like the schedule is just crazy
i was looking at it i think just the
next three weeks there's like
six seven events or something i was like
bro that is a lot of tech events from
around the world uh thanks to tekken
online challenge returning right now for
2021 uh and it's so cool that they're
you know tapping into multiple regions
as we mentioned like new regions i
should say uh that we really haven't
seen players compete from uh you know
south africa here being one of them of
course you know we haven't seen any of
these players at this level uh you know
broadcast on the official tekken channel
etc right so this is a really cool
opportunity for players and scenes
around the world yeah and it's again a
nice way to highlight it we're in
getting into our top eight so we're
gonna see some of the players and how
they're able to perform under pressure
when it comes to you know getting done
with the tournament and i'm excited to
see this because you know i want to be
able to kind of build on the experience
and the storyline for these players and
kind of see how they do not only uh
through this event but also again for
the regional finals that are going to be
happening uh in a few months time
exactly
um take a look i see x-star did move on
in the bracket can we pull one nice okay
not out of the pool yet but uh you know
working the way through the pool
basically to get to that final against
frost
but looks like we do have another match
coming our way
i'm guessing this could be from pool
three maybe
we got proxy versus oh ghost proxy nice
against cloud so ghost proxy one of the
players that i heard is one to watch out
for uh we got some buffalos in play
going up against katarina oh boy
you know i started playing online again
recently and obviously this is for north
america but uh i noticed there was way
more large players than i remember did
something happen is he more fun again
happened
does this character get decent uh wasn't
he already decent
yeah he felt like he was always decent
but i guess they made him more fun
because i think that's what it really
comes down to for a lot of the online
plays how fun are they to play online
dude i mean that fun buff is is is it
goes a long way his wall carry is so
crazy bro he could hit walls in open
stages he's going to hit a wall at this
stage he's taken to the train
there you go dude this is crazy but here
we go load not in their proxy
thanks donald pursue to start it off
it's crazy because you know oh my god
god hedge of snake
no combo though all right all right
opportunity you get hit by snakehead you
don't get a calm you're like all right
cool we're still in this
damn empty jump while that one oh boy oh
boy oh
mimosas just again getting away with a
lot of these little nice counter hit
low again
all right there you go that first
round two
it looks like a struggle bust right now
the round hopkick
remember if you're not out of control
you're not in control walking up
oh again he's a sniper with that low
this is crazy nice working that lead
here goes to the fourth one plus two
throw able to get it
oh and the catch on her head
do you believe in magic
two rounds straight for mimosas
oh boy
oh he's got the damn lars out for that
gives you the music uh oh yeah all right
i'm not a fan of proxy anymore
nice gets the low the follow-up here
gonna confirm into a combo
down four two one
oh missed the the kick
into the throw
oh going back the other way does not get
the combo over at all
orbital into the drop this is not good
but go over the low looking close it out
in a normal grab
able to take it two rounds of one ghost
proxy on the board
throws are working right like in these
situations you gotta be like all right
what's working for me what can i do
about it the orbitals have been good and
the throws have been good
oh
didn't hit the button
i thought the kicks were going to come
out at the very least
uh-huh into the red knee the follow-up
here goes for the hair you're low
the running attacking
yo but now he's only got a small pixel
here i'm almost this
good block
yeah
and he risked it all there obviously he
was at a sliver of life left good block
there on the rage drive follow up into
that low and go got the launch let him
know it's not free not free but first
match to mimosas
yeah definitely
uh looked like struggle bus for a ghost
proxy there a couple of opportunities
you know but just not capitalized
completely right and actually this is a
run back so mimosas oh double jeopardy
on the winner side of the bracket oh
man
i hate those
i hate it was two to one before though
can you imagine like just going to
tournament and you only lost to the guy
that you only lost one guy
and it wasn't in grand finals that sucks
right i mean that's how it goes
sometimes though right you're in a pool
you're like oh why is this guy in my
pool i know i can't beat him uh and then
you just happen to meet that guy before
the top eight and before the top eight
again you're like well i guess i'm going
out at night
yep well we'll see you maybe there are
there maybe there's time for some
adjustments there is you never know
there is time there's definitely a match
that's only one in the books
we'll see how it goes but again thank
you everyone for tuning in i know at
least in our region it's bright and
early it's four
uh close to 4 30 a.m uh if you're on the
east coast top of the morning to you
yeah and for everywhere else around the
world hopefully you're enjoying it is
obviously prime time uh in uh well not
really prime time close to lunchtime
over in south africa
all right let's see switching it up to
lucky chloe yo you go from lars to lucky
chloe that's toxic in my book
i like it i look at that
right you've always been a fan of lucky
chloe i have been you know i i used her
when she came out right yeah at the very
start in the beta phase
the beta phase in the arcade phase in
the arcade phase when it wasn't on the
console yet
yeah
uh no i think this character is only
improved too you know across the seasons
uh yeah i think definitely underrated
the fun buff she definitely got the fun
buff oh yeah certain things like one of
the things i love the most out of her is
she has the running mix up now is having
that instant hell sweet blow right yeah
that's one of the coolest things and i i
think i think being able to do that at
point blank and then mixing it up always
fun to see anyways going into it nice oh
my god mimosas doing such a great job
here's oh no missed the downforce
doesn't matter we got hopkins
what's happening this is what i'm
talking about right here dow thief is
for all day
all day
yeah goes for the oh my gosh
here we go the follow-up here should be
able to get the wall into the follow-up
3-4 nice what's the mix oh you just
looked at it
this this is a great choice from ghost
proxy here
i mean the fact that he's on the score
oh my god counter hit
yeah and most you know like you can tell
like not afraid to throw out something
in the starting round like we've seen
snake edge hop kick
all immediate right opening gamut
attacks
wow
if you panic just to get the block and
there's a hopping man mimosas is
terrifying i don't want to play against
mimosas like dude it's like you don't
know you know a launch is coming you
don't know which one you know you got to
block correctly
you're trying to get it here we go
okay again the patience got to be
careful got hit by the counterhit
looking to close it out and there it is
mimosas taking that round back tying it
up one a piece
you got to do the down people before
exactly
except you got it part of it yes yes
three plus four
seems to be the weapon of choice here
early on in the round please don't get
hopkins
oh yeah that's i mean that's that's the
oh my god and don't get snake edge oh he
thought he was near the wall not able to
get
it not quite but a great step into a
throw
oh here we go
it's it's still hit
oh god look look at those goes for the
mid this time rage drive answering back
oh my god okay okay okay i almost had a
heart attack
seriously he got he got the cali roll he
got to the wall and almost dropped the
wall combo
oh my god star of the round is all
mimosas every single time
through the doubt yes yes the dow thief
was four all day damn that's the mix up
go for vertical hopkins but i've never
done that that's smart
oh oh look at those tying it up here we
go the hairier low
pretty much a perfect and here we go
final round here big round for mimosas
to qualify into top eight
ghost proxy please
dance autumn yep
oh
fighting
oh
hello the law again might be able to
close it out here one more mix-up oh
that was great or low but why didn't it
launch that was it looked like it was
countering it i think she was airborne
oh no
that's done
damn he tried to hop kick out wake up
too but nope
mimosas gonna hang on there
and move into the top eight with that
win double jeopardy for ghost proxy
losing both times to mimosas
uh that is brutal two to one and this
time two zeros so mimosa's moving in top
eight with that one with the catarina
it's always much more brutal because you
know it was close you had a chance there
taking it to the final round could have
tied it up but again it wasn't enough
but unfortunately uh for ghost proxy out
of the tournament mimosas moving on so
that's another one now for our loser
side of our top eight as uh we kind of
get into things there are only maybe two
more matches for losers qualifiers
before we get into the top eight we got
um we have our winner's side top top 8
already
finalized
you guys can type in exclamation point
bracket in the chat
to give you an idea of what's coming up
let's actually talk about uh some of the
stuff that's happening for the tekken
online challenge for the rest of the
year
so uh let's go into it you guys can see
these are the dates we've already gone
through some of the regions we're
currently in region number seven for
south africa you see the online master
events for the rest of the year leading
up towards the early part of october
then we switch over in november to our
regional finals events and south africa
is actually the first one so we'll be
revisiting here first before anything
else and of course that goes on until
early 2022 where we have our north
american event at the very end
yeah that's wild man so many events
around the world and of course if you
guys want to register uh get yourself
onto this leaderboard make sure you guys
check out the website
tecadashesports.bn.cnt.net it's kind of
a long one but there you see it on your
screen make sure you guys get in there
and register since your points will be
tracked across all the dojo events that
you guys enter
yeah and again the deadline is coming up
so make sure you guys go ahead and do so
you got to submit your application
online our team will review it and
approve it for the event but make sure
that obviously you cross all the t's and
dot the lowercase i's and js
and of course guys don't forget if you
guys want to follow all the action make
sure you guys follow us on social media
bne esports on twitter and youtube and
also tekken across twitter twitch and
facebook
oh yeah there's always a lot of clips
over the be any esports uh twitter
channel our twitter account you guys can
check out all the highlights from not
only this event from past events as well
of course if you want to see the vods
check us out on the youtube but rip we
have more matches coming up we are going
to obviously get into more loser's
qualifiers as we get into our top eight
and i'm excited because again we've
already seen some some character variety
we saw a little bit of the new stuff the
dlc we saw some matchups i did not
expect to see did not expect to see
lucky chloe versus katarina to the newer
characters
actually you know let's say i had this
question i saw this question in somebody
else's chat as well as you know
sometimes i browse on twitch and just
watch a bunch of uh tech and streamers
uh big and small and one of the
questions that came up is let's say
there's a new game right
okay
out of all the tekken 7 characters
which ones do you think would make the
cut let's say only four of them made the
cut
out of only the new tekken 7 the new
character so i'm talking about like
lydia leroy uh [ __ ] rum
uh and then chloe claudio
katarina if you could only pick four of
them in the next game who do you think
we would see
claudio
um
why claudio what do you like about
claudio i'll be the pit by four first
clock
like [ __ ] wrong but available don't
like pakoram you know like would i like
to see him again probably not just
because he left a bad taste in my mouth
uh and then kazumi
but she's dead you know like she's lower
wise you can't bring her back now again
right
uh and then you've got katarina
the chat is very vocal they've improved
katarina over the time but still not fun
gigas i've used some gigas i like the
character but i don't think that we need
a gigas in the game
uh
josie just give me bruce back you know
like she's cool and all but she's she
doesn't have the back too man i think
that was like the coolest part about
that well maybe you just want back to
back what if what if [ __ ] rum had
back to you
if pokemon or josie had back too merge
those characters give them bruises back
to call it bruce and sure put that
character
well they're going to give it to look
chloe then that's awesome yep
well interesting okay
interesting okay you said why claudio
though i think for whatever reason um i
kind of like the starburst mechanic you
know oh yeah it was a way that you
didn't have to introduce meter to tekken
but you could still make the characters
have some kind of resource to manage so
i thought that was a really cool
addition that they did uh and i don't
know are there other characters that
have something like that still
um
no i think claudio
is the only one that has anything like
that where he has a move modifier right
i think
yeah or additional well yeah well it's
actually funny because they changed them
where he could do those moves or do
certain certain versions of those moves
without starbursts but obviously they
were less powerful
that was a change that happened a little
bit later on oh we got div versus king
and this is again a qualifier
this time versus x-star uh this is not a
qual factor the winner this one gets
frost to qualify to top eight so we're
one away from that one as well
uh-huh
oh nice
counter would get a kick cobble from
expo or just far away
oh oh that was risky going for that big
tackle here
nice counter hit
as the wall here oh it drops the
massaging
doesn't matter right into the the the
low poke there
yeah that looks like maybe it wasn't all
the way at the wall so i think he
hesitated a little bit
but doesn't matter catch our kid with
the first round here
oh here we go
oh i thought he was going to get it that
would have been crazy
especially if you got the screw out of
it here we go finalize
boom boom
into the running power bomb
what's the okie
down forward for the classic
albatross slows oh my gosh counter hit
forward four neutral two these
counterweights are adding up here oh
yeah
good block
oh my god
he had insurance baby bro they both had
insurance that was crazy
different layers
okay blocked
that is guaranteed of course that
extended duct two afterwards
oh my gosh you gotta be careful
gotta make sure it counts
yo that was
tight cat door kid steve is sick
oh
hi shades of t4 push him into the wall
keep him there let's see what he does
ghost with the low oh man
he bet it all there
yeah that was a huge bet
and i guess he's been going for a couple
of four four neutral too so we hope he
had conditioned them
damn the following you know really
calling out the deepest like cattle kid
i know you know about this back when
children hit the back one four
[Music]
until then
as the wall oh look at the damage adding
up what's the mix about the wall
peekaboo low
where's the giant swing at where's the
giant swing at
oh
no
is it enough it's not the beat down into
the beat down though that'll steal it
catch our kid
looking impressive so far i want to see
who sent cactual kid it was frost to
send character a kid to the loser
bracket actually and frost after that
lost callum so frost waiting now might
be another double jeopardy situation if
cactuar kid can get past x-star but it
does seem like extra understands the
matter right there's a couple of
opportunities missed
yeah has a chance still so we'll see
that was just the first match
i'd love to see some throws
i don't think we saw any king throws
there
i know right isn't that weird i mean
in combo doesn't count no exactly right
i mean if you got if you got the
character like king or even arm king
with his multi-throws uh you have to
take advantage of it right it's one of
the strengths of your character
but there were there were a ton of
instances where he did get counter hit
though so i feel like maybe he's a bit
afraid of the counter hit game because
there was a counter hit back one there
was a sway into the launch there was a
lot so far so uh let's see that i guess
it's more of a when you're fighting
steve especially it's a timing thing you
have to know when to be able to kind of
strike and take your turn and it's it's
always scary going up against them
especially when when you consider like
the speed of the back one right or the
evasiveness of these sways so i'd like
to see the adjustments here but again i
think there's a lot of opportunity the
way that he was kind of working his way
in with like the ford board
neutral two the low yep um maybe maybe
some more lows that would crush
naturally crush uh what what steve's
strengths are which are the highs maybe
just generic down fours i think that
could go a long way
yeah i mean things jab is not bad either
king's jab is crazy
one of the i think it's like one of the
most damaging jabs in the game
really it's interesting
and i mean if someone if someone can
check in the chat like just his one two
i think his one two does do more damage
than most
not counting the like the special ones
like the knock down ones of course yeah
his his punch are like 10 and uh is it
11 favorite for back one
it's well either 11 or 12 11 or 12 right
yeah uh regardless like the damage on
both of those punches are pretty chunky
but here we go picking the forgotten
realm stage here smart choice but oh my
god he did the throw at the start and he
got countering
uh boy that's the rough one and that
yeah
it was a good call out at first because
you know it's gonna crush that back one
but obviously the date is adding up here
wow just get up and gut punch
uh oh that was definitely a mistake you
wanted to break the floor there
didn't get the shining wizard
wow
that one should have been a hotkey for
the whip punish
he's already had the capital punishment
locked and loaded though
hello fairy good here
are we breaking at this time oh huh
nuts
wow
yo that was great risky super risky
right the get up kick versus the sonic
drive there very nice works out oh boy
that was unfortunate this is like a
series of unfortunate events at the
start of each round so far
but hey uh xlr had the last round so
maybe this is how we like to start
parties into oh my god i saw that
hitting too but the get up kick
[Music]
what he does here he's playing really
oh my god are you serious
he's playing to beat the back one right
so the power crush the high crush
uh all this is etcetera right as like an
attack statement but really he just
needs to change up his timing
yeah
it's like he is every time that three uh
kaktar kid goes for that back one he's
swinging and he you don't want to go
heads up with that it's like a going up
against 18 wheeler
oh oh
yes shiny touch the knee
there it is that's what he wanted the
first time where you got beat up by the
low kick this time the timing of the 441
able to net him encounter it
yeah actually see what he does with it a
little bit
double albatross
nice
the first there we go
yeah it's okay if he breaks it right you
just want to keep that pressure on
make him break it yeah it's also kind of
forcing you to find out whether or not
they're they're breaking them and it
puts you through the test like he broke
this one will he break that one oh my
gosh smell it frankensteiner let's go
x-star answering back ties it up one
game a piece uh the stage definitely
helped out a little bit there but i
think he only got one of the floor
breaks right so that was that was a big
shift though that was a huge shift
because he went from i feel like he lost
even though he won three out so i feel
like he lost every round it was crazy he
just put it together at the very end he
was able to pull it off so good stuff to
him x-star on the score we're tied up
1-1 now now if you're a cactar kid you
got to be thinking like what went wrong
there i was hitting my counter hits but
the thing is he got hit by everything
everything towards the end it's not like
he got thrown to death or anything like
that it's just uh
i wouldn't even want to say that x-star
like had the timing over him it's just
everything that he threw out ended up
landing
yeah the shining wizards are starting to
add up here right like those one plus
two grabs uh and now that the throat
game has been established at least a
little bit uh it's gonna get really
interesting to see the third game how
character or kid responds right cause
some players once they start getting
thrown they're gonna start looking for
ducking right uh as a state player maybe
you still want to just go for the back
one and just try to counter these throws
like i don't know how effective that is
i've never tried to do it you know as a
steve or even like as a magic four
character right uh but
it could be an option uh personally i
prefer the duck you know it's more
rewarding if you're ready to get that
launcher if you dug and grab
uh but right now but steve what do you
do to really punish from other than like
while setting one too
uh watch just duck to grab and get the
full launch is it full crowd downfall
plus two or they change the notation i
don't even know it's full crouch uh from
crouch down forward too okay yeah but i
mean who does that i mean you still have
to do that yeah
you gotta have see you know if you have
if you my my point is that if you feel
like you want to duck for a throw then
be ready to launch the whiff throw right
like if you if you ride on the reed and
it's a read situation like he's gonna
throw me i'm going to duck and i'm going
to try to launch it uh then you can get
it it's obviously steve's launched a
little bit slower but you know if you're
looking for it that's the whole game
plan uh you can make it work
right in the open
i like it no walls to worry about the
giant swing
just wait i mean
i mean we'll see we'll see if he gets a
giant swing and he doesn't take it
that's something to worry about
anyways going right into it starts off
with the low
oh nice oh
in condom ducking he's catching him
mm-hmm
uh huh what's the wake up
into the downford four
falling apart a little bit for a cat
door kid right now
right now x-star he's uh
he's making it work the ten count throw
damn i got throws too
classic matchup boxing versus wrestling
clash of two different worlds
this is very boxing nowadays yeah i mean
shades of uh oh yeah actually yeah
shades of like one of the first mixed
martial arts bouts from back in the day
antonio enoki versus muhammad ali
this is where the ali ki came from i
thought you were gonna say like uh rocky
versus hulk hogan you know
well yeah there's also that thunder lips
versus rocky match but yeah
but this is actually where the that term
from king's down three plus four that
series olly kick was from that matchup
oh
i did not know that yes they actually
had yeah they had that exhibition match
and the only move that the wrestler
antonio nokia could do was the the the
low kick
that's why they called it the ollie
kicks
interesting
but right now x-star running away with
it april state's not helping out
character kid here uh-oh
dude he's going in
he's got it
down one two three
oh my god
the bunch of dragons the follow up here
oh he didn't let it rip
would it not have hit
nice
that does have a a lower oh a lower
hitbox with shining x-star with the big
lead still oh my gosh
you still get to follow up you got a lot
of time afterwards but that was pretty
gangster nice combo
is that enough running exploder into the
mid
time it oh no oh my god he holds on
that was crazy
that was crazy because it missed because
he hit him in the aerial state but man
he still made it work
it's a sonic game hard for steve convert
that but man luck on cactuary kid's side
we're not he's rolling with the momentum
bro this momentum though yeah x-star he
is not afraid to swing as soon as he
gets up off the ground we see the wild
end two two and
multiple times
wizardry shining
i like it you're a wizard hattie oh my
god he had the side he could have had it
that should have been it
oh my god they're rolling so bad out of
here close it out i i thought he was
going to get away with that if he did
the sway punch and killed him from that
that would have been crazy that would
have been amazing very fun match to
watch there but it is x-star who will be
moving on has to go up against frost to
make it into the top eight still uh but
very very fun match to watch their
catcher our kids steve fox very fun to
watch uh but does not convict and goes
out here to x-star
[Music]
oh
coming up next x-star versus frost to
qualify into top eight
nice looking forward to it mm-hmm
i wonder if we know what character frost
is using frost looks like lost to callum
in the winter final of this pool so
definitely a force to be reckoned with
obviously
uh but man i'm still thinking about that
steve fox but that was so fun to watch
dude you don't really see people go what
do you call steve's backsway you know he
ducks the matrix i just call it the
matrix matrix
damn uh yeah the snake charmer is that
the name of the move that the punt that
comes after it
uh
i don't know the exact name i'll have to
make it up i need to brush up on my on
my move name well you know what they
changed between games too so a lot of
the moves so i know they did a revamp
they did a revamp between like tag two
and and and the games before it
okay damn nyk is awake though send those
smash it in though smash is direct
okay awesome it is snake charmer send
smasher and it's a good punch i mean if
you're an epo fan
i feel like steve fox is a love letter
to that that manga anatomy i need to
watch it still it's not very long right
it's one of the longest running mangas
out there
so but an anime there's not that many
seasons yeah it's it's it's it's pretty
short
it's like
so we know x-star is gonna be using king
uh we saw him adapt with the the throw
game uh overall very very effective
right and uh coming up off the ground he
likes to tech roll into buttons right
it's not gonna be a gut punch off his
tech roll or a while standing two two so
if you're approaching him off the ground
you gotta be really cautious about that
right uh frost we haven't seen yet so
i'm really curious about what we're
gonna see out of them yeah excited to
see the character choice but also just
how he's able to deal with x-star king
because very momentum-heavy x-star once
he started feeling himself he started
going in we started seeing uh more
cheeky stuff like you know jab instant
shiny was almost at point blank rage he
was making things happen so we'll see
we'll see how
i mean you won that last match you're
like you're feeling yourself you just
need one more to get into top eight i
would feel it we'll see we'll see how he
does
uh and definitely you know you already
got like the stream jitters out you know
and now he's going to go up against
frost
first time on the tekken channel
probably right this is uh maybe a little
bit nervous this is your this is your
stage it's your opportunity to show the
world what you can do
uh so i feel like as a player from a
region that's lesser known i feel like
this is more pressure than usual
because you know just players in general
when they get into a stream for the
first time like oh my gosh people are
watching me uh but you know this kind of
pressure it's got to be a little bit
different right it's like sometimes you
go to offline tournament then finally
get an offline major and you get on
stage it's a different feeling right i
feel like this is the same thing for the
online world
yeah for real very very important is uh
to get the jitters out there and again
sometimes it never goes away for some
people sometimes it never goes away yeah
you know we were talking about uh pdx
the other day and how you know he
recently he's an online player went to
offline went to summer jam and he tried
to
uh block out him he came back tweeting
about how like he wants to use
headphones and really focus on blocking
out the crowd and everything and then
you had that red bull house thing that
just happened where they were training
with like lights and crowd noise and
everything to simulate the experience
i'm like this is so opposite you know
like uh which one is the right one to do
you know personally i feel like you have
you can't really block everything out
you have to at some level and you have
to learn making noise yeah yeah make
noise for yourself i mean that's one of
the things is like
honestly i'm going to be very honest
like for players like pdx i've never
heard of him prior to
the pandemic and online tech and play
and stuff like that i i don't remember
seeing him at events maybe you have but
uh i think having that experience is
crucial having that experience having
people yell in your ear when you're like
the invader going to a different area
that's the kind of stuff that'll help
you as a player overall
yeah i mean we've been doing it for a
minute right i mean i remember it was i
think evo 2007 uh during tekken 5 dark
resurrection and it was that was like
one of the evils where a lot of the
reasons across the us came together and
those big old team region battles 5v5
and everything and people were loud like
the regions would be right behind you
really loud you know rooney for their
boys and like any mistake you made they
were letting you know about it and back
then we didn't have astro providing
headsets for everybody you know like you
had
you couldn't hear anything but the crowd
but there was no audio
you could barely hear
those those old asus monitors
oh my god oh man the good old days but
shout out to astro for helping change
things around because we do have
headsets at most events now yeah
courtesy of them anyways we're going to
go into this looks like we are uh
the violet stage let's see
how this is going to work out because we
know x-star is going to be bringing the
king
definitely what are we going to see from
frost though fight i think oh it's large
there's large players everywhere name is
tekken police oh
is that technically an m cop i was going
to say the same thing i was like this
guy napcop
might be undercover different branch
they have a different branch yup
nice
shoeshine follow up here goes for the
sidestep attack afterwards x-star
keeping his distance now but good good
user of the lows into the nice break oh
man to counter it confirmed over three
into the throw
through the wall running knee
interesting okay never mind
wow i like that actually
a little off time dark blast
and i thought you don't think very solid
here
i was getting mentioned though he is
just standing still though
and that's going to open up largest
forward forward oh
that was sick the wall game they're able
to do that back to when is that 442
crossover mixed up that stuff is dirty
that stuff is dirty
frost on the board now though
wow
oh man and you know x are you swinging
here in these weird places
i feel like there might be some large
inexperience but again oh
nice stuck into orbital he's trying to
mix them up
should mix them
uh-huh
drive oh my gosh
delay a hop kick
normal
oh my gosh
if he had more life that would have been
it but man that sucks
yeah you're right oh man x are no punch
on the whip that time
brain you serve that shoe shine the
follow up nice side step afterwards
though he knows his options he's shining
the [ __ ] out of those boots
oh oh the conversion he's still gonna
get it not a lot of damage because the
aerial state
see what he does here what's the mix
into the multi oh no
oh he is going to put him in the bridge
crossing the river
boom broken back
all right what's the mix now
oh mid
oh wow
that wasn't even a whiff punish he did
something after that that was crazy here
we go final round
double that keeping the pressure on now
frost
where the shoe shines
oh boy that's a big shine
and the power crystal wall doesn't get
anything giants bring nice tech
underneath ray drive spent
it's cool
he caught him i mean he's been using the
frankenstein quite a bit trying to even
up my life running exploder roll forward
oh my gosh this might be it second india
oh my god the comeback
x-star
stealing that one at the very end there
was a huge life lead there but
unfortunately not able to close it out
and x-star again continuing that
momentum of the last match
yeah that back one two punish and then
the downboard one delayed two caught him
uh and you know anytime you get hit by
the second that you kind of panic right
so like he froze up there and extra like
i'm going for the low kick you know
betting my life on it could have been a
low parry situation i could have forced
a block out of him but doesn't matter
still got it collect stuff there from
eckstar really uh to hold on and get
that victory from the way that final
round started for him
yeah we'll see if uh he's able to
continue i mean i'm i'm a king player
i'm going to cheer for x-star here
it's uh i mean we've seen most of his
path uh into the top eight so far at
least on stream he's the player we've
seen the most so i i definitely like to
see him get rewarded in that aspect he's
like our early favorite just because
he's the one that we get to see winning
the most you know we're like extra
remember him guys we saw him winning all
day on stream uh but yeah of course
we're coming to this tournament like
halfway through already right like a lot
of players who entered we had like
almost 90 players enter this tournament
uh most of them already eliminated by
this point we're just down to basically
the top 16 as we wind our way into the
top eight here uh and x-star we saw him
get a victory a second ago over cactur
our kid uh now if he can get past frost
we'll make it into that top eight uh and
i believe we're that'll make it seven
out of eight i think we got one more
match after that to round out the full
top eight
oh yeah
of course we're gonna get back into the
match i wonder if we're gonna see a
character change
i mean we saw i i mean we already saw
lars quite a bit on stream
yeah we have um
i think the largest is working out
though you know i don't see a reason for
him to change it but let's see what he
decides
it's gonna be a switch
we got dragon off coming up here bro i
feel like i have the reeds of knowing
when people are gonna switch characters
how do you do it's magic
i i guess like everyone else
it's a good strategy
i'm just going to guess it's 50 50.
going to be one i'm familiar but i'm
familiar with the players it's an
educated guess but what i'm guessing is
guessing
i mean even when it's an educated guess
i usually get it wrong like when i see
bin chang play i'm like he's gonna
switch characters right he's got like a
hundred and he does it like i don't know
it's because in your heart of parts
you're always hoping for heihachi that's
true
all right frost let's see if the dragon
off can turn things around here to help
you get into this top eight x-star just
needs one more game though
oh beautiful
side step down four two four frost here
and gets into the wall what's the okay
finds nothing was hoping he would step
probably
one plus two snow is good
wow that was such a risky downpour too
there
oh he probably could have got a little
bit more out of that unfortunately not
able to do it doesn't matter gets the
block and the punish matt xstar
he's uh he's going on a journey he's
trying to get into that top eight
oh no
counter running two for frost now
another early
well that was an interesting option
running powerbomb
from what i've seen so far a lot of the
okie options have been
uh not for grounded opponents right like
a lot of them like i want to track you i
want to catch you i want to relaunch you
uh but something you need to play
smaller seconds
yeah compartmentalize be more compact
give yourself some room to react oh my
god
it's gonna hurt this is gonna hurt
boom
at the wall too
rolling
nice
goes for the string tying it up on
rounds here frost showing sides of life
that spring always looks like a country
thing but it's only like a six hit
string or something
all right it's over
bro i almost
grabbed my mouth you know because it's
like not even 5 a.m here dude my
neighbor's gonna get pissed back one two
blue stuff get it out of here power
crush
oh my goodness yo x-star is crazy dude
a 4-3
no oh my god
someone ordered a double shiny
don't you
fight
dragging off camera sir
nice gets to grab the follow up here
what's he gonna do
down to
i mean i don't know what he's going to
do at this point frost is not able to
really open up xrx star once he gets the
momentum he goes crazy yeah the crazy
thing is frost has had like a good start
to every round but he keeps using them
that was a good punish though on the
atlas hammer he got the launch of course
punishable let's see what he does here
he does have the life lead but he's
gonna get put into the range one more
hit
oh oh this is how every round is gonna
be like big lead for frost and the
officer next door with the comeback
somehow
oh boy just throw him where's the wall
at throw him farther
oh my gosh he's gonna come back there it
is over it's over
man the spring kick is not gonna help
you in the open like that you gotta be
careful but it doesn't matter
x-star man he he just uh earned his way
right he's in now right now
he's in the top eight congratulations
x-star uh and you know frost he had a
lot of big life leads and i think he
goes back and watch that set he's going
to realize that once he has that life
lead he's got to change his play style
you know he's he's giving too many
opportunities for the opponent to allow
the comeback like that's bring kick at
the end there unnecessary right just
hold back stand up you're cool man
you'll make it you'll survive and then
you can play tekken again but if you do
the sprint kick you're like what are you
betting it wasn't even going to kill him
right it was too much of a risk for that
situation
yeah and we are of course uh about to
get ready to go into our last match that
leads up into our top eight um to see
who's
oh we're not gonna be able to see it so
uh we'll find out very soon who's going
to be going up against xr i believe that
match is underway but as you can see we
already have seven of the top eight uh
you want to go room rip
sure we got callum versus big daddy mike
to start off with tops out of the
winners then we got groupie going up
against dvk so that's our winner side of
top eight down below of course we've got
extra waiting for his opponent and then
we've got onyx going up against momosus
uh mimosas i think probably right uh not
momosus like i keep saying it but uh you
know there's a good variety of flags
down here uh and chat please help me out
when you see these guys on the screen
let me figure out these flags i might
just google it i'm about to google
south african flag
there you go
add it
no i know the top one is south africa uh
the rest of the whole boy
that is uh that's gonna take me a second
you know to figure these all out
also if you guys
are familiar with of course tekken you
probably are a fan of a lot of the
characters and these awesome shirts are
available now from 10-0 make sure you
guys check out the good ass tekken
shirts the king shirt now back in stock
you could of course scan that qr code on
the screen or check out 10-0 gg slash
merch of course there's also a law
design
and a bunch of other designs just make
sure you guys check out the website back
in stock again for a limited time i love
that yellow law shirt man i wear that
outside i feel like a sunflower
and then i spill hot sauce on my shirt
and i'm sad oh really
dude that's the problem with the white
shirts oh no
oh yeah i still have mine it's i'm still
i'm still chilling with the guys and of
course if you guys want to keep up to
date with everything going on tech make
sure you guys follow us on all the
social channels you see on your screen
right bnd esports on both twitter and on
youtube that's where you can get all the
esports clips and matches etc and then
you've got tekken on twitter twitch and
on facebook as well of course you guys
probably watching this on twitch right
now so make sure you guys click that
follow button if you guys are new around
here uh give them a fall on everything
else as well yeah and we were just told
from the top eight we have all types of
obviously representation from all over
south africa region it was south africa
mozambique kenya
zambia and madagascar man that's crazy
to even realize that all the all the
different uh countries and nations that
are represented in this event no exactly
so uh very very cool as we mentioned
multiple times broadcast already you
know just tech and online challenge
branching out to these new regions that
we haven't really seen uh competition
from so it's really cool to see you know
how people are doing from across the
world uh see what characters are being
represented there and how they're doing
with those characters and how people are
dealing with things uh very very cool
that tekken has expanded like this so
shout out to bannon namco of course uh
for broadening everyone's horizons a
little bit
oh yeah
so i believe we are gonna go and break
let me check with the team but i think
we are gonna be back with our top eight
so we'll be back in just a bit see you
guys soon
uh
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
my god
[Music]
uh
bandit is down in gun range
[Music]
arrived at destination
[Music]
enemy reinforcements check your radars
[Music]
box too
[Music]
welcome back everyone tekken online
challenge for south africa my name is
mark i'm here with rip and again we've
seen a lot of great matches leading into
this topic and we're finally ready to
start but before we do want to give a
big shout out to our friends over at
astro gaming the official headset and
mix amp of the tekken online challenge
rip how are we feeling about the topic
we have quite the representation from
the different countries in the region
exactly we got players from all over the
place we take a look at the bracket in
just a second uh you can see we've got
three players from south africa we've
also got representation from mozambique
kenya zambia madagascar as well so
pretty good distribution of players and
regions and characters here in our top
eight today
oh yeah
very much looking forward to it that
we're gonna be kicking off things uh
with the winter side of the bracket
right so we got callum bukes going up
against big daddy mike uh he's gonna be
going up against dbk afterwards uh there
you see the next match is coming up
those will be our winner's side of the
bracket whoever wins these matches will
be guaranteed into the top three of the
tournament uh then down at the losers
side we've still got x-star versus
onyx versus mimosas coming up after that
so
definitely gonna be an interesting day
here to see who ends up taking this one
uh the first tekken online challenge for
the region you know so someone gets to
be the champion you know they'll get a
hold of that forever you know the first
tekken online challenge yeah south
african champion you know that's a
pretty cool title of course this is a
master event tons of points are on the
line so whoever wins this is going to be
in the lead in the region which would of
course do them well as we qualify into
the event that's going to be happening
for the regional finals that's going to
be happening in november it's going to
be south africa for the very first one
so hopefully these players are ready for
that looking forward to that and again
all these points are going to go a long
way i don't think there's i i don't know
these dojo events are i mean there's
like close to 90 people here they if
they bring in more and more people they
could have some significant events
through their dojo points as well but
again there's only so many that they can
do prior to that that cutoff date of uh
early october
yeah definitely right because it's
october 10th i believe it's cut off for
the dojo event so not a lot of time to
get your points and to make that
regional final obviously and these
events here are going to be the big ones
we can get the most points so today's
points going to be the most significant
in terms of how the players shake things
out to make it into that qualifier but
here we go this is going to be winner's
side of top eight coming your way it's
gonna be callium versus
big daddy mike eddie versus brian fury
gonna be twilight conflict for this
stage
yep
two characters we haven't yet seen
uh from from these players or or on
stream at all so i wanna see how of
course this play out i'm a big eddie fan
uh i feel like he's just one of those
characters like once you have movement
especially if you have the ability to
kind of back that weave in and out it's
it's a it's a sight to see it's like to
be old
and he's definitely back dashing he's
one of those oh yeah he's he's he
understands how to play this character
he'd make winner's side top 8 for no
reason oh yeah those pants aren't just
for show counter it
nice good conversion here goes for the
down two
i always three that it's crew in the air
therefore
i mean it should be right
it looks like it yeah
but they did give it uh
in the most recent balance update they
did give it homing properties which you
did not have before you were able to
sidestep it
i mean you could still jab it but i mean
at least it has its homie now you can
jab it no way
yeah you can you can easily float him
out of it in the in the opening frames
of that of that attack
right now though callum what the lead
he traded right there
nice slow jab follow up here
oh he went for it
do it again
oh boy is it going to work it
definitely is that's crazy
with that wally behind eddie you never
know where he's going to go
but look at that perfect there survives
in just a pixel calum
first two rounds because of it
what was to throw get off me
hatchet down two up this time
the challenge man cal's looking
comfortable right now
change the misery let's go
oh no
that might be the entire game actually
wall carry here
does it live he's alive
oh my gosh into the mid
good stuff man that was very impressive
very dominant uh and able to kind of
close it out of the end there so first
match in the books already
yeah calum looked really comfortable in
that one right and he wasn't really
phased you know like double hatches like
that's fine i have a good life lead uh
you saw the back dash canceled they're
very clean from calum uh you know he's
an eddie player and he if you put him on
the infant stage i feel like you know
he's gonna just run away forever so i'm
out i'm out of here
he's looking like a strong container to
take the whole thing right now we'll see
uh
big daddy mike has an answer for him uh
but yeah some things i saw like you know
he went to relax and big daddy michael
for the down back too like does brian
have a better option to pick up relax
and get a better punish off it it
depends especially on what you want to
do so obviously if you transition into
another move right away that down back
to would have picked up but because he
just stayed neutral it did not um
there's moves like down three two which
would have splattered him into a wall
but i could have put him in some thought
okie so it really depends on what you
want to do i see but down back 2 is
generally the best option if you know
they're going to do something afterwards
gotcha
so right now calum
big chilling is what it looks like you
know the throws the throw breaks have
been good for him the movement has been
great from them uh obviously offense and
defense have been on point so far you
know not really a lot of holds in this
game but i'm not really sure what big
daddy might have to change to really
make things work out for them the match
up specifically with brian and eddie i
mean obviously you and eddie made
yourself
you know like what do you feel about
like is that always been like a problem
matching for brian or is like eddie
comfortable there um i i really think it
depends so uh he looked comfortable
because his ability to kind of get weave
in and out of the action so he
definitely looked comfortable there but
brian
any of the characters that have really
fast attacks that can really kind of
close out things and force eddie to put
in risk to kind of beat out i'd like to
see uh big daddy maybe go for some back
ones some jabs because you know eddie
doesn't have a sidestep he doesn't have
a strong sidestep i should say one that
he can rely on consistently so i think
using things that can kind of help space
out in the matchup maybe like three plus
four back one that will help go a long
way
gotcha wow great low prairie here to
start off all right maybe uh bear
defensive options could help too
oh yeah go for the taunt
was just the threat empty threat i don't
know
i don't know we'll see i mean
oh oh he had the knight stuck there down
back to that by two is a great move as
well
the only thing is you gotta be careful
because eddie does have some great
counter hit tools in the open
and it does have the threat of a really
really fast wall setting one
but of course it's high so let's let's
see if he's able to pull something out
here again with the 12 frame back three
as well if you can counter hit confirm
oh no there's that while setting one
this is gonna hurt big time relax two
four three the follow up here
what's the mix
the hatchet kick oh i like the downward
one oh my gosh
greedy greedy and look at that first
round to calum again
that was
a big mistake like he had the life lead
right and time was winding down he had
the pressure he just gave him a low
and callum took it
[Music]
huge lead yeah there's no need to put
yourself into risk here so that back
dash is very smart here using that
standing forward very fast mid attack
causing problems here big daddy mike
he needs this round otherwise it's all
over and calum is going to move on to
our winners finals
five rounds straight callum running away
with it right now
mix
oh no punish he could have went for the
big launch there the jet upper would
have been the right move
nice good down back to the follow up
here let's see what he does
oh that could have been a launch
gotta be careful
again the back dash you got the lead
don't take huge wrists here orbit yeah
oh
you just said it dude don't take big
race he's like how about a low poke you
won't kill him but what's the worst that
could happen yeah got to be careful into
the drive
again out of range there oh it's over
northern crossings
yeah he just instantly dug full crouch
attack there very nice
i mean it's a great move it's only jab
punishable i i would go for it more
[Music]
nice back one again another one another
one oh my gosh
if eddie does block that though he's
gonna get a lot so he's gonna have to be
very careful at how he places those
hatching kicks
[Music]
all right big daddy mike's turning
things around can he stay on the
winner's side of the bracket right now
there's blood on the dance floor oh here
we go the follow up
i hate that new move i want to duck it
every time
yeah it looks like it's duckable too
because of the slight delay like oh let
me duck
damn double vertical orbital the taunt
dash is to stay up with them that's so
cool actually
oh nice japanese oh this is huge
lifelong up here
okay yo what is he doing
you gotta make sure the top hits oh it's
not gonna be enough
it is enough it is enough wow that's
impressive
big daddy mike this is why you calling
me big daddy tying it up
[Music]
and calum right now
i i don't know that that he he was in
the lead right going into this
like he was in control then he started
taking those risks those risks started
coming out and then you know he just
capitalized so big daddy making it work
bring us the pivotal game three now
you're like don't take any risk right
this how about a low kick move orbital
did not need that that was very very
impressive by big daddy mike they're
very nicely done mozambique the only
representative from mozambique in this
top eight right now uh and staying alive
on the side of the bracket ties it up
one apiece impressive comeback there
uh man i really
don't know uh what to say about because
you know callium callum really looked
like he he was in control right he
looked like he was running away with it
everything was going his way uh big
daddy mike wasn't punishing correctly on
some things you know it really would be
difficult and also second game they went
to infinite stage so i thought really
callum was going to just run away all
day uh instead it turns out that big
daddy might just turn things around a
lot of hatchets right lots and lots of
hatching kicks as you mentioned eddie
can launch it but uh he actually hasn't
launched one correctly right he did that
one where the watson one is late but
then the second lost them anyway uh who
knows man
but here we go either way three
this is going to be the big one very
important another open stage
infinite azure
pressure's on now though
guaranteed top three finish whoever wins
this game
come on
here we go i have a feeling he's gonna
back out of there oh he went with the
down four two to start it off running
slash kick there it's another great move
that kind of restricts and catches up
towards where eddie's at as well nice
low jab
no he doesn't get the float
second hit nice goes for the downpour
four
and again see i feel like it's kind of
forcing calum to actually start using
more of these tools more of these low
attacks which is gonna put him into a
bigger risk later on
fisherman's slime could have happened
there did not connect
and big daddy's doing such a good job
like he's got the likely here you can
tell calum's like much more nervous and
approaching
oh my gosh
not looking good but here's the
follow-up there guaranteed now that four
chord four
got the weight spent as well big daddy
looking good here just doesn't have to
take a big risk don't go low is what i'm
saying running out of time
nice block
back one didn't need that but hey it
worked out
first round a big daddy mike who now has
the lead here in the match
hatchet
oh
big daddy looking really good now it
looks like he's in control now in
complete control which is a big
what a punish that was crazy nice whip
punish
yeah that's something we haven't really
seen out of calum yet right
yeah then down four three plus four
excellent range on that very fast dude
it's 15 frames so
did get the buff over uh tekken legacy
time
that's huge yeah it used to be 17. yeah
dude what the heck
oh boy
wait the 50 really try it again
do it again
is it follow up here
hey nice the low the oh my god
his legs are gone as far as i'm coming
collected there it is
blue stuff back at him do it do it now
uh-huh time
oh my god are you guys going low end of
the round oh
that hurt that one oh my gosh i don't
think that's what he wanted i think he
wanted the four forward four he got
forward four instead
here we go right now big daddy mike on
the verge there's the punish we've been
waiting for it the follow up here two
four three i just realized
straight now big daddy mike's five
rounds straight
uh-huh
see what he does here
oh
big daddy mike this could oh my gosh he
dropped it
you got to be able to clean your plate
finish your food
he's got a back dash do not take a huge
risk do not get oh my god
he's running this guy goes out the round
oh my god he's all caught up
the drive is gonna hit for calum he's
not out of it yet right when he forward
dashed he ate the blue stuff so right
now
calum staying alive nice step there man
he knows
eddie's m42 does not have amazing
tracking at all but that's when he got
it mixed up there's a 4-4 there we go
ouch
nice stuff
follow up here back three three into the
follow-up combo unscaled on the last hit
oh he almost he could have launched
there
rage mode
you know he's gonna do that blue back
one it's coming
here final final round calum versus big
daddy mike south africa versus
mozambique to make it into the top three
oh you got to be beautiful
it's not going to do too much damage
though
has a chance here let's see what he does
yo now big daddy's desperate he's going
for these lows
but he's gonna have to be aware almost
every single low that he can do he's
gonna get launched punished by that
while standing one 1-3
yeah mike
30 seconds left oh he was like he's cute
it's gonna he's not gonna be enraged
he's not going to be rage let's see what
he does now he's in the rage
and he's still living
oh my god
oh my gosh
that's crazy
that was so much damage so fast you
thought it wasn't going to knock me rage
but it did and that damage afterward for
each of those hits increased because of
it
wow
that was so unfortunate for callum but
it will be big daddy mike moving on to
the top three that sequence he built
that up over time because he went for
that spin into the low and the last time
he did he did it twice in a row right
and then he went with the hatch this
time he went with the mid and obviously
you know what's eddie gonna do he's
gonna duck he gets hit and that
guaranteed follow up from that down
forward four into the soccer kick and
that was all that was all he needed
and of course that was the first time
we've seen these guys on stream right
now so callum sent on down to the lower
bracket here gonna be waiting for the
winner between onyx and mimosas uh but
big daddy mike sitting in that winner's
finals top three guaranteed waiting for
the win of our next match which will be
droopy going up against dvk that was a
really good set though that's
amazing mozambique and winners finals
let's go
coming up next we've got south africa
versus kenya uh with groupie for south
africa dvk from kenya this time around
uh so it's gonna be someone else that's
not mozambique it's the only play for
mozambique in our top eight for big
daddy mike so congratulations to him so
far uh especially for just you know
guaranteeing himself a top three finish
here but that set was so fun right
watching the players go back and forth
calum five rounds straight big daddy
mike five rounds straight back at you
and then it wasn't over right obviously
callum brought it back another two
rounds final final round situation uh
everything that they had built up
throughout the set right all the mind
games obviously paying off in the very
end and just that that last combo he did
we just like i thought he wasn't being
rage either right uh and then sure
enough he was in rage and then he really
comes in there you know survive the
folks he's five three pokemon that
didn't kill him that five hp herodicare
came into play and obviously he just
watched something like watch this
spinning low boom the enrage soccer kick
you're dead yeah three unscaled hits in
rage it added up super quick and that
was all she wrote but up next we have
droopy going up against tvk
this one i am excited to see because
jupy one of the players that we've been
hearing a lot from especially in the
chat so let's see if he's able to
perform and maybe uh get a chance into
that winner's final slot where he can
fight off against big daddy mike and
then after that we go into our losers
bracket matches which again we saw most
of those players play earlier today so
it'll be exciting to see which one of
them is able to make it especially
x-star x-star he's been doing the most
work at least on stream anyways we're
going to go into this the other side of
our winner's side of the bracket and we
got oh oh it's
versus miguel
that is not at all what i thought we
were going to see
miguel versus horung here
winner side of top eight
uh boy that's very very different you
know so we've had eddie brian miguel and
horon here
for south africa region
quite the variety in topic yeah
wild character variety here you know i
was talking earlier when we started the
stream about you know whether we'd see a
lot of the dlc characters and instead
we've seen none of them for the winter
side of the bracket right only on the
lunar side
look at the damage that was four seconds
uh-oh
this is the follow-up doesn't matter
going for that backlash really
brandishing it out there
man he gets tall he is towering over
i've never noticed how much taller he is
maybe it's his hair
he is way taller than laura
he's probably taller than martin he's
probably tighter than [ __ ] wrong too
just like everyone else's
just like everyone else yep
not as advertised
it's it's like that that meme is like
hey mom can we get [ __ ] wrong we got
[ __ ] mom at home
oh here we go nice plasma blade
follow up here
here we go we got the wall
oh nice talk
ready for it full launch punish here dvk
whoa how do you get away from there
here we go tied up on rounds
[Music]
man that was that all started with that
very clean whiff punish they trade blows
there
[Music]
again
sometimes you just got to throw it out
there that back oh my gosh the art of
interruption dude that was a crazy
backfield put in that position
try to test him there went for the mid
launch
transition parabellum kicks the follow
up here
oh
and dbk didn't believe in that one
launch would have been the round but
here we go get the throw
he went for the low bbk up two rounds to
one here let's see what droopy does what
kind of adjustment
he's been playing pretty well i mean
he's been getting all those hits but
those those uh folks ended up adding up
you got to break those throws
oh
do it again yup in the chest
that's not the wall it's a good time
instead of doing bob's belly you might
as well
nice now the lows are coming out the one
thing that we really haven't seen from
droopy is the use of the lows to kind of
open up his opponent uh oh oh my god
come back oh don't get a problem
run up and just do the low for the ray
drive
reset the situation is gonna go for it
low jab oh my god erotic hair is it a
rage drive
boom
combo
wall boom
perfect combo from dvk
smart stuff miguel
getting it done here
yeah and of course having that rager
i've really helped uh if he hadn't had
that he wouldn't have gotten a screw
otherwise so he was able to pull it off
and good stuff to dvk taking that first
game here in our in our winter side
match yeah that erotic error is uh been
very important the last couple of games
that we've seen in the last couple
rounds we've seen uh but very nice stuff
to dvk the miguel's looking clean you
can tell that both of these players it
looks like they've played each other
before that's what i'm seeing i feel
like they're very familiar with the
matchups
the punishers are on deck you know
they're ready to go uh especially each
other's tendencies but uh i'm still
impressed with what we've seen so far
out of uh groupie and dbk right that the
back three passenger interrupt that he
did i was like whoa that was something
you wouldn't normally do just against
any other unless you knew what they were
going for specifically you know
especially since he's launch punishable
too it's like you're throwing out a huge
risk there but still he had the
confidence and you know i'm pretty sure
he hit most of them he did if not all of
them in in the set
oh yeah
uh anyways we're done
we're gonna go back in there droopy uh i
don't think we'll see a character change
i think we'll see more horan um again
big match here to get into our winners
finals this is definitely a position you
want to be in obviously you know you're
going to lose bracket you have to play
way more matches so
uh especially in top eight very very
important as we go into this
here we go brimstone and fire
fire
yeah sticking out hurong definitely his
main
knocking me switching away from it you
can see the letter grades there looking
like he's got some good grades miguel's
grades not so hot didn't do so well in
school ccd come on
i gotta say like um the the south
african community they're very active at
least in the offline scene you know we
see a lot of clips and we see a lot of
uh stuff from them through uh online on
twitter and stuff like that we see a lot
of their their events and their their
tournaments uh i wonder if maybe just
online is not something that they do too
often i mean i i've noticed like i guess
based on the ranks that i've seen from a
lot of these players maybe they don't
play ranked maybe they just play player
matches but either way it's nice to see
of course these players going at it
there's the wall just short of it
yeah the ranks are definitely not an
indicator of their skill level oh yeah
nice sucking launch again
and you can see he's got a lot of
experience either against the character
or against groupies in particular right
because his his launches are just locked
loaded ready to go every time
uh-huh goes for the wall street four
fourth
oh my gosh he took some damage there
this is what i want to see though i want
to see droopy start going for more of
these low attacks more of these risks to
really help him he gets the wall this
time that's going to hit
nice ward 4-3 looking to close him out
and goes for the mid
there you go there's that round
sometimes juan needs that momentum
yeah efficiently backlash from one
distance really hasn't been working out
for him
nice try nice ride a little bit late
here we go nice good block
oh but that big again at the wall you
might as well do it
double low jab to close it out man here
we go dvk one round away from moving on
let's see what he does here jupiter is
really gonna have to turn things up
[Music]
oh my god i could have had something
there
[Music]
oh he's at the wall he's got to be
careful he back dash while in flamingo
he's dead
hell and dead and that will be that
quick work for dvk
to guarantee himself a winner's final
position here very nicely done dvk
droopy sent on down to loser bracket not
out of the tournament though uh but you
can tell there dbk he really knew
exactly what to do with the horizon
match up oh yeah so dvk and big daddy
mike will be battling in our winners
final later of course that's gonna be
extended set a best of five but now we
are shifting our focus into the losers
bracket
let's go look at some of that action
that we just saw big daddy mike and
calum they had an amazing set early on
you know callum
really started it off and kind of set
the tone for the match he was in the
lead he won i think was it five rounds
look at the health oh my god oh my god
three three hits in like two and a half
seconds dude
it's really just two hits that he needed
right the third was guaranteed that's
guaranteed and that's what rage does is
like if you guess wrong you are in for a
world of hurt
yeah that was just absolutely ridiculous
man the the set with calvin big daddy
mike so it will be big daddy mike moving
on and dvk so we got mozambique versus
kenya as the winners final of this
region so far
oh yeah and then our next match i
believe it is going to be x-star going
up against unga bunga who we've not yet
seen on stream yet so far
so looking forward to that let's see how
that of course is going to be playing
out
and then following that we will have
onyx going up against mimosas
we've seen next start with the king
we've seen mimosas with the katarina uh
have we we saw onyx too as well right i
think he was our first match on stream
maybe yes we did see onyx earlier today
so next matchup of course x-star uh from
kenya another fellow kenyan player going
up against unga bunga who is from south
africa yeah the
uh all the south african players are all
the country of south africa all those
players are in the loser bracket
together now right all three of them uh
so we'll be able to see which one of
these guys makes it out uh if any of
them into the top through the tournament
right because we got x-star unga bunga
onyx mimosas plus from the winner's side
drop to lose we have calum plus droopy
as well right so a lot of action yet to
go
and don't forget guys we have a bunch of
regions that are being represented in
the tech and online challenge this year
obviously we're down here at number
seven right now region seven of course
tomorrow we got the middle east you can
see all the other regions listed and
then starting in november we have the
regional final event starting right back
up with south africa yet again that's
going to be november 6th guys and you
see it working all the way down until
early 2022
i was about to say 2021 again it's 2022
that's when these things will be
wrapping up with north america on
january 9th so you can see on your
screen right there tons of regions and
representation from players around the
world
all right the players are getting ready
to go and you know it's it's crazy to
think about you know rip the last time
we had an actual second world tour event
um what was that it was in 2019 in
thailand right that was the last time we
had a live event i should say so it's
been quite some time you know the game
obviously has evolved and shifted into
online so it's crazy to see
um you know the different i guess
tactics going into it and of course uh
one of the the other things that we're
seeing is is so much more representation
from around the world and you know the
different regions that we're
highlighting anyways it looks like it's
going to be a matchup between kunimitsu
and king that's who um is using it's
kuni mitsu uh another character that a
lot of people kind of have been talking
about lately um due to her efficiency
yeah i mean you know when a player is
named unga bunga i like seeing that
their character choice is kuni mitsu
because this character can definitely
get um oh yeah let's see how he decides
to play i think this character can be
played very safe or he can play very own
gabonga but uh we're going to see what
he decides here x-star we saw very
oh my gosh
yeah x-fire has been the star of the
losers bracket so far from what we've
seen you know he's obviously made his
advance here oh my gosh right now he's
playing he's going in
that uh from crouch down forward to he
made it count
all right there he goes he went for a
toe kick there interesting
xr taking that first round as we go into
it let's see what unga bunga is able to
do here is it is it like um
or is it like controlled um that's what
i want to know
yeah right now it's looking controlled
to me
yeah maybe a little bit to control
because x-star is is able to land a lot
of these hits so far oh my gosh
okay the bunga might be coming
all right one way to do it is with
lowe's oh he went for the power crush
but he got shining wizard for oh my god
he if that hits the wall he's done
it might be short of the wall
exploder
oh that was a stick he charged oh my
gosh oh i hit him with his cover hit him
hit him you want oh my god he's wasted
are you wasting my sparkles hella wasted
the sparkles
oh oh nice nice option that hits around
50 oh boy all right good choice there
x-star staying composed here i feel like
we need to normalize key charging as an
attack a pressure move
oh yeah there are so many there's so
many crazy setups that you can do
uh-huh here we go
so many low counter hit launchers and a
lot of characters oh my gosh the spring
kick it starts come back well setting
three here we go yeah that was the face
down feet away into the wall standing
attack there from unga boga
khadex start off guard something to look
back later
i do i've never seen that option that's
crazy
yeah you get like 442 guaranteed i'm
pretty sure it's guaranteed yeah oh here
we go shoulder
into the swing again yo x-star if i'm
x-star i'm doing giant swing all the
time now because he's not broken him
too far one plus two shining wizard will
give x-star the game
nicely done x-star chilling big chilling
right there on the bucket really didn't
get started right the round three looked
kind of good uh but the rest of it
really not working out
are you sending a character switch
no
no i mean stick to cootie mitsu
well i i i don't know honestly
let me let me think i have to do this by
feel just because i'm not familiar with
the characters or the players yeah so
let me see let me think
this is going to be a good test of my
feels
he's going to stick to kuni
feeling he's going to switch
okay we'll see we'll see how this goes
the reason i say that is because
cootie's a relatively new character
right so
he was playing something else in tekken
7 beforehand and the kuni got kind of
smoked there so bring out the bunga with
the other character that's what i'm
saying
okay i mean that's it that what other
character do you think
this is a huge guess because there's you
know a lot of characters
that would be so funny let's let's get
on character let's bet on character come
on what do you think i think it's
yoshimitsu
okay i think it's martic
wow
wow okay all right
i think that if you're a cootie mitchell
player you probably are from the mitsu
line you know like you probably
comfortable okay okay
sword all right all right yeah
right otherwise it could be something
like wrong i'll tell you one thing i am
sure of x-star cannot change his
character i'll say that yes i think
we're in agreement on that point x-star
gonna be sticking out king definitely
been our hero with the loser bracket so
far and he's he's really the younger
bunker too right like i mentioned
earlier you know if this man is if you
can knock him down he's tech rolling
some kind of two button attack is coming
your way it's gonna be wild and two two
gut punch two you know like something's
coming so you got to be careful
but right now it's looking good for him
you know up one game here moving on
could be the top five if you can get
past unga bunga
yeah of course we have one other match
here in the losers bracket
uh before we get uh back into the swing
of things man we're gonna see some of
the players that we got knocked out of
the winner's side earlier that you just
saw and again there were some great
matches man that first match with calum
and big daddy mike that one was crazy
went down to the very very end
yeah i wish we had started the stream
with that it would we'd have been out of
energy by now you know uh yeah but gotta
conserve i mean it's early for us
i don't know if you're like awake yet
but i'm definitely awake after seeing a
lot of these matches so it's good stuff
i'm shocked you know i didn't realize so
much time ago we've been here almost two
hours already right it's uh it's 5 40
a.m out here on the west coast of the
united states so it's it's quite early
for us uh but we've had some great
matches so far you know and still more
to come i'm sure right now i think we
got
uh we're tied up we're one zero right
now right so
we'll see
if we can see anything crazy out on the
bunk i hope we do i hope we get a
character switch
is it
no i told you i told you damn you're so
good at this
i really thought it was gonna be a
switch i was like very confident that's
why i asked you i was like he's going to
switch for sure right he started the he
started playing kuni mitsu
and only kuni mitsu now i'm playing i
don't know
he just got a tekken 7. he's heard about
tekken he's like what's this i like this
kuni character
gonna pick that up make top eight of my
first tournament ever
all right here we go mishima dojo
see how this plays out here nice goes
for the sobato this time see the one
thing i want to see from
he needs to force the interaction more
he needs to like do things he he got
that big low you know early on with that
from crouchdown 403. he needs to
put the mix on even side to four right
he landed side support didn't take the
guaranteed 442 afterward either
so he's not taking the guaranteed
forward forward two situations he can
have it and he's not really going for
them as much key charge again with no
health left and you can see this is a
bad idea because it's going to be like
an up for three or something something
relatively safe from extra he's not
scared of that key charge
and xr is not afraid of ducking he's
been ducking a lot of the stuff that
ungo has been doing as well i don't know
if uh
okay he didn't duck that time this time
going for the 442.
nice power question at the wall has been
working out for him right when he's done
a little bit further away it's been a
little bit scarier but right at the wall
working
okay okay
again yeah this is gonna hurt
this is maybe where he turns things
around let's see what he does ollie oh
my gosh
oh i was like just hit the brakes a
little bit
wow he could have killed him right okay
he got him he got him all right all
right on the bunker time go
fight this is a great name it's like my
favorite name so far from all the
players
this is definitely one of the coolest
names i told you technical walt disney
two two hop kick
what'd you do that was
damn
oh the follow up gets the combo the
bunga it's coming he's getting under
what the hell we try to do some crazy
stuff
he might hold on there i don't know
hey the blue stuff oh
the mid and the running oh man all right
all right
trouble right now for unga bunga x-star
looking to advance
yeah trouble in paradise to see x-star
will he be oh that's a big block that's
a huge block he's gonna get the wall as
well but what what's the option he goes
to the ground throw
oh my gosh it might be over rip it might
be over oh it's over we're rolling it is
over we're rolling
the under the bunga he's danza damn see
you later x-star moving on in the
bracket
rolling death cradle very nice yeah he
did his uh
he did his favorite impression of like
katamari damacy just started rolling
that [ __ ] was crazy but man i saw right
there i was like oh he went for the
multi he's gonna kill him and he made it
he made it count that was good stuff
yeah very nice extra definitely the hero
for the stream right now bringing out
all the king trick that everyone wants
to see rolling death cradle moves x-star
farther along in the bracket he'll be
going up against droopy next uh but
still we still have onyx versus mimosas
coming up winner if that gets callum
uh just to make it into the top five of
this tournament
but man nice try from mongabonga goes
out seventh place congratulations you
know almost 90 people entered this
tournament so seventh place not a shabby
showing at all yeah gotta be proud of it
and again for the very first tekken
online challenge the first master event
for this region it's great stuff of
course getting points here by being in
the top eight we're going to be going
now of course to the other side of the
losers bracket where we have onyx and
mimosas two players that we've seen on
stream already uh
throughout the tournament day
so uh any thoughts here on who we're
gonna see do you remember who which
characters they played earlier remember
what character onyx used because i
remember mimosas was the katarina we saw
i think onyx was lars wasn't he
i think it might have been i remember
those are lars in the first and second
matchup so
it seems there's been a lot of lars
actually you know there has been a lot
of large his uh rice the popularity
again is kind of crazy
right yeah i think you're right
aha so we just had a player uh with a
little bit of a delay so we're gonna
fail a little bit i think is what that
means i just translated everything for
the stream chat
but uh definitely i think it was a large
player mark and i think you know we've
seen the catarina the katarina we saw
was like very high-risk reward style
right like we saw oh no no onyx was a
jack player wasn't he
oh you're right you're right he was he
was jackman very good jack player he was
going up against the liddy that we saw
in spaghetti as our first match of the
day yeah the first match of the day i
remember now okay got it yes yes but
onyx was very strong but uh against
mimosas his catarina style as i was
mentioning you know very high risk
reward right like start of the round
he's landing a counter and he's going
for a snakehead he's going for a hop
kick
so you gotta be really cautious start
around against them and even if you get
the launcher it's gonna be it's gonna be
kind of hard you know to uh to get it
done against them so
we'll see
what onyx can do here uh it's it's gonna
be
a very interesting matchup for sure yeah
and it's gonna be zombia versus
madagascar so
uh
i'm not sure topography wise or or
geography likewise i think where they
are overlay dude we need to look up a
map check an online challenge we need to
have like an app that comes up and like
it's gotta like highlight the countries
for the players so we can see where they
are in the world i think that would
actually be a really sick feature by the
way production
yeah that would be cool good good
2022 next time maybe uh i mean honestly
i would learn a lot even for like eu or
even america sometimes you know the
states you're like where exactly is
connecticut i'm not really i was
thinking about that you remember how
when we used to have offline events we
traveled the world
really we literally traveled the world
to kind of be at these events and do
commentary and kind of help host and
highlight these events
we have seen quite a bit of travel uh
based on our love for this game
and man
can you imagine like you know let's say
we do go back into a situation where the
world's in a better place a safer place
we're able to travel the world again and
to see all these things i mean we've
been to so many so many places and again
we've only touched
at the tip of the iceberg
in terms of different tech communities
around the world i mean i i haven't been
to pakistan but obviously they have a
huge uh they have a huge uh community
there and that was really one of the the
communities that was really kind of
brought to the forefront uh over the
last uh twt year that we had offline um
you can look at all these regions here
again we have the online master events
that are happening we're currently at
region number seven
uh out of the 14. so we're almost
halfway there throughout the online
master events and we have of course our
regional finals that are happening in
early november all the way up until
january of early next year
uh any any any particular regions you're
excited for i mean we already had our
north america one which i thought was
was fun oh yeah i mean it's always fun
right oh yeah for whatever reason i
think when you're watching your region
play it's always fun uh but in
particular tomorrow you know the middle
east is going to be up here and that's
the region too where we haven't really
seen a lot of the players you know out
in the big stages you know and you know
players even from like san diego cayo
like i don't think he still plays
anymore i'm assuming he doesn't but it
would be sick if he entered that
tournament tomorrow you know and did
well uh that would be amazing i would
love to see that
how about murad is morata out there
still i wonder i don't know i don't know
where he is but there's been obviously a
ton of great players from the middle
east anyways let's uh before we get into
the matches check out some of these
awesome promos from our friends over at
tenno we have the good ass tekken shirts
back in stock right now for both king
and law you can see that blue shirt and
the black shirt available at 10-0 gg
slash merch there's also a link in the
chat
that's popping up every now and then you
can also use that qr code to be directed
directly to the site
exactly we also got the good ass tekken
marshall law shirt got it available in
either yellow black i like saying gold
or black but still it's yellow or black
whichever one either one you guys can
fit at the same place 10-0 dot gg slash
merge scan that qr code and you guys can
get in there
yeah once they're gone they're gone you
know this is the second time we've we've
made a batch for these just to the
popularity from this first batch uh
people ate it up and a lot of people
were asking us on social media and
elsewhere if they could get a chance to
get these again so this is your chance
so hopefully you guys take advantage of
that there are pretty much sizes
available for each uh each one of those
shirts so make sure you guys check it
exactly but we are still working our way
here through this top eight guys so uh
bear with us we're just waiting for one
of these places to get back in here
and after that here is the bracket right
so we have onyx going up against mimosas
right now
as we mentioned that will be
jack going up against most likely
katarina that's the
characters that we saw earlier today for
these players onyx from zambia mimosas
from madagascar wynnum winner we'll get
callum uh and calum we saw has that
ridiculous eddie right uh ridiculous
back dash probably matt's the day so far
if you guys missed it earlier make sure
you guys check out the archive and go
take a look there because callum versus
big daddy mike was just a ridiculous
phenomenal match great adaptation on
both sides you know down the wire uh you
can't really get a better tech mess now
to be honest it was it was really really
fun mass to watch
but of course so far we still have
groupie going up against x-star and it
looks like mimosas has been disqualified
update live on the bracket just like
that onyx gonna be advancing
uh which means that he will be going up
against cal next and that or maybe not
next but in the bracket later at least
uh which would be eddie versus jack how
do you feel about that matchup
oh it's tough because of the tool set
that jack has i feel like eddie can do
it it's just a matter of patience and of
course making sure you're able to kind
of back dash and get the right read the
the scary thing is is like you can't
reliably punish a lot of the lows that
jack has because he can recover and
crouch like from his from crouch back
one so that while setting one will not
hit so you have to kind of rely on just
your spacing and try to try to whip
punish but again the back dash is great
though for eddie so it really depends on
how on point you are in fighting up
close
yeah that one should be an interesting
one so we're gonna get updated i mean
obviously you know with that
disqualification that means that the
schedule of the line of matchup that
we're having is going to change a little
bit uh so we're still waiting on word to
see what happened guys but we will fill
you in when we find out as well
yeah so
[Music]
all right guys and don't forget make
sure you guys are following us bnd
esports on both twitter and youtube if
you guys are watching these events and
tech and online challenge events or if
you guys watched any of the events in
general uh the b esports channel on
youtube is where you can find a lot of
these highlights and clips from the
tournaments uh the bne esports twitter
account also has a lot of live uh clips
too as well right then you've also got
tekken on twitter twitch and on facebook
so make sure you guys go and drop them
all a follow
oh yeah and of course we are gonna get
back into the thick of things but we are
going to be taking a quick break as we
prep the rest of our top eight matches
so we'll be right back after this break
he went afk oh my gosh
that sucks
how long ago how long how long did we
give him
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back guys check an online
challenge for the south african region
i'm rip here with mark man without the
shades what happened
i just wanted to prove i have eyes you
know just in case there's some people
talking to chat that i have no eyes that
i lost them in in the war but no i still
have them yeah you're actually
okay
oh man but we are in our top eight right
now guys hope you guys having a good
time watching us out here uh max has
been acting pretty fun to watch you know
that callum versus uh big daddy mic
match earlier dude that one was crazy
absolutely it's very very fun to watch
oh big daddy mike's in the chat what's
up dude uh great stuff support and good
luck to you uh later in the tournament
but of course guys this tournament
brought to you by astro the official
headset and mix amp of the tekken online
challenge uh shout out of course for
supporting all things tekken across the
ftc lately as well so a huge shout out
to astro for all that
yeah of course we are going to be
getting back into the matches i believe
we'll take a quick look at the bracket
as we see where we're at right now
unfortunately we had to uh have a
disqualification from one of the matches
earlier but as you guys can see of
course we are getting pretty deep into
the tournament uh we are our winners
final we have big daddy mike and dbk who
have uh fought their way over there but
in the losers quarters we have droopy
going up against x-star the king player
that we've seen really uh kind of
dominating uh throughout the losers
bracket so far we have callum who we had
an amazing match up with big daddy mike
earlier going up against onyx the jack
player
so that's what we have uh coming up so i
hope you guys are looking forward to it
as we kind of figure out who is going to
be getting all the points and of course
the title of champion here for the south
africa region
exactly we are currently in our five
remaining players uh we're gonna have
our horong vs king matchup is what's
gonna be one of them and the other side
of that we're gonna have eddie versus
jack right so that's gonna be the loser
side match that's coming your way in
just a second uh but we are setting up
for that guys and as i mentioned uh very
very cool to be here out in the south
african region dude uh so so crazy it's
just not something i ever expected that
we would be doing uh
you're mentioning that you know we
travel the world like
it's a long-ass flight to go to south
africa it's like from from where we're
at it's like you were our flight or
something you were there i remember
there was this point in time i think it
was like in 2019 or maybe it was yeah it
was 2019 where you uh you you you
traveled you went on some time off from
streaming and then you you went to south
africa and i i think a lot of people
probably don't know you're originally
from south africa
exactly yeah i was born in south africa
lived there the first eight years of my
life you know now that i'm 17
i've been in america
i've been here for a minute uh yeah
definitely not definitely i did grow up
in south africa uh you know like a lot
of my extended family is still out there
you know so i do go and visit every once
in a while so 2019 was the last time i
was down there uh you know and things
are more or less the same as i remember
them uh you know obviously a lot of the
country has been through a lot of
changes obviously so uh very cool to see
and you know i did get a visit cape town
which i had never been to before like
i'm more if for those of you guys who
are from south africa i was i was born
in durban you know johannesburg was like
where my family is so uh cape town is on
the west coast right it's always cape
town is the the southernmost point of
africa right
i
think it's a good question it's
definitely down there
close yeah well it's definitely not
north africa it's south africa we'll
just we'll leave it at that but when i
when i went out there right to cape town
my sister and i tried to go great white
shake shark great white shark cage i was
like whoa that sounds fast he doesn't
want a cage yeah great white shark cage
diving but apparently the the waves was
too crazy so they wouldn't let us out
yeah so that's definitely something you
guys can do if you guys go visit cape
town uh and it's like one of the cool
spots in the world to do that apparently
so go check that out if you guys are in
the neighborhood
yeah definitely in the neighborhood
thing uh
i guess what i want to ask you is what
do you
out of all like it's crazy that you
mentioned that so like hopefully we'll
be able to have like a live event in the
future sometime in south africa i think
that'd be awesome and you kind of be
like uh you going back
home right that would that'd be cool
and to be able to kind of see tekken uh
one of the events that i loved in the
past that we went to uh as we get into
our next match i'll talk about it real
quick is when we went out to uh rev
major for the philippines
oh man that event is awesome you see i
mean tekken fans all over the world and
just seeing how how into the game they
are just it's just a sight to see in
philippines has one of the best
communities when it comes to just love
protection
by far you know i was like always
jealous when you guys were there when i
saw it on the the streams like the first
year you and steve went and everyone's
like crowded around you guys at the
commentary table and everything i was
like damn that event looks cool and you
know i'd heard everyone talking about
how crazy it was but then when i went
there myself i still wasn't prepared i
was not prepared yeah it was crazy about
the philippines
yeah it's crazy it's very very awesome i
definitely definitely want to go back
there without a doubt that was the best
but here we go losers matches continue
well droopy's using fang now yeah
switching it up and yeah hey man that's
earlier that's the flavor of the of
season four so far fenway i mean it's
it's not the wrong way i'll tell you
that
it's the fang way all the way yep
here we go tempo step i get oh with the
second eight he wasn't ready that's a
high
yup
here we go
i haven't seen anyone use that up for
three plus four string
since i was testing the move list out
for tekken 5.
you're saying you're saying this yeah
i was like oh it was useless
oh here we go
yeah and that that back kepler stuff was
so strong in the early days of tekken 7
right they actually slowed down a little
bit uh because i remember specifically
it was uh jdcr versus neat in the
philippines
and uh you know it would be dragging off
running
and he would kenpo step it wow
yeah finn gets off the ground weird man
you got to be ready for that but that
was also slightly off axis he has a jet
pack he got a little jet pack on him
anyways droopy with this change oh okay
that is not safe and that again was both
of those moves were not that was crazy
interesting sequence there x-star has to
be on point here
i like that forward three into down back
three that was a really good mix
oh okay
okay he he got greedy with that and
finally he got punished for it nice
nuts and you know one of the big things
i'm noticing too goopy he likes buttons
dude you know we saw him as a wrong
player a second ago and now he's fang
he's very buzzy right so that backwards
butts oh yeah buttons yes he likes
buttons
he likes lots of buttons
i like big buttons and i cannot lie oh
three rounds straight for droopy
man um you know he had some momentum
there but again we've seen x-star in
this situation before where he would go
down and he'd have to make some
adjustments and make a comeback can he
do it again as the hero of the loser's
bracket timeline will he be able to come
back this time the king here he wears a
cape for a reason you know uh we'll see
if we can get it done here though uh i
think groupie he's playing like a man
like who's upset about his loss from the
winner's side of the bracket you know
he's like he's got a statement to make
that's what i'm feeling right now out of
him uh out of seeing the way he
approached that matchup with his fang
right so
i'm feeling like droopy he's ready to
move on to this top four ready to bring
it all the way back to whoever sent him
down here in the first place
so i think you know we've had we've had
a lot of fun x-star so far
but this is definitely an uphill battle
here this is a test and and again there
there's obviously seems to be some intel
there because droopy not using warong
who we saw earlier today uh he's went
straight to fang and he dominated it was
three rounds straight it's like he he
knew that this matchup would be in his
favor
yeah he plays so fast too right like
he's constantly keeping you guessing and
then he's either like forcing your turn
like it's like oh is it your turn now
it's going to be a back cancel step or a
backswing blow like you better be ready
for it right so he really likes having
control of the offensive flow of the
matchup so far uh we'll see if x-star
can turn things around here and you know
going back to that first that we saw
with x-star there were no throws again
here you know and like these seem to be
the games that he loses and it's
probably like a feeling out process i
think he's one of those players that he
needs to go through some rounds see how
what the opponent is doing you know
before he can really start working his
game plan in
all right let's see how the game plan
works out he's gonna of course stick to
king
and we're gonna go back into the matchup
this time random stage into the arena
all right let's see how this plays out
holy moly x-star has eleven thousand
wins
holy moly i don't think i've really seen
anyone with that many wins eleven
thousand it's a lot
well maybe he does play he plays online
for sure
damn a lot
time to use that that uh that experience
put it all together
you get the wall yet he does doesn't get
the follow-up it doesn't matter
rolling sobato
man he has the wall do something there
you go here we go
oh
he didn't go for the screw
yeah
he's gonna have to realize that last hit
is high
yeah i mean definitely not a movie you
see a lot from penguin but oh the back
turn makes goes with the low this time
full launcher
groupie running away with this one
factor mix again wow that looks sideways
right that was weird yeah that was
definitely an interesting uh situation
there now xo the whiff
into the low and look at that droopy
running away with it again uncontested
four rounds straight now
oh forward kenpo now
it really slowed things down here
[Music]
[Applause]
and they're now starting to use a little
bit more of the tool set here from
fenway that quarter circle ford one a
great approach move especially if your
opponent's not able to react to it
nice max range beautiful oh my gosh and
he beat out the ford ford one range by
going for that reverse kenpo into the
launch looking to close it out and right
now jupiter is looking way too good and
there it is
shoulder iron mountain
for the finish two rounds to to none and
again that's five round straight right
now for droopy
yeah x-star gonna have to do something
drastic here to turn things around
factor makes nice back dash out late
no he's not he's not he's not getting
punched he's i don't know what x-star
what's going through his mind right now
but he needs to get some offense started
yeah i think he doesn't know how to
approach here right like
what is even the best approach to i mean
even like the fourth one maybe oh no
that will do that
oh my gosh god that should have been a
hot kick oh
no
not gonna happen x-star out at fifth
place droopy moving into the top four
and no he had a couple of chances there
that finally hit that round right that
toe kick whiffing if that was a hop kick
there that would have been perfect but
unfortunately not ready for it uh and
we'll be out of tournament fifth
yeah very dominant though from his
opponent because six round straights man
you gotta think about it droopy now able
to move on wants to get back in on uh
maybe have revenge against whoever comes
out in the grand finals because he has a
long way to go so he still has two more
matches if he wants to be able to do so
he's going to be facing off against the
winner of calum versonix in the losers
bracket so that match of course is
coming up next as we get ready for that
uh callum who we saw earlier using eddie
gordo um
he was playing out of his mind his back
dash at some point his whip punishing
was on point but it wasn't enough uh to
take down uh
big daddy mike earlier exactly
uh but you know droopy i think also an
interesting point just to go back to
that last match really quick you know
his fang looked really good and i was
thinking man maybe he should stick it
out with fangir but honestly his horrung
was really good as well right he just uh
came up short in that matchup that he
had against dvk's miguel but uh gonna be
very to see what droopy decides to stick
with as far as character goes fang as we
talked about definitely character that's
gotten some buffs seems to be very
strong right now uh and droopy seems to
know how to use them pretty well as well
so we'll see what happens there but it
looks like we're ready ready for the
next one let's go calum incoming i'm
gonna assume we're gonna see the eddie
out of him and from onyx we're assuming
jack of course but let's see what we get
oh my gosh
[Music]
maybe
maybe he doesn't like the eddy matchup
with jack that that's interesting
anyways i feel like i feel like claudio
is a really good option against eddie he
has a lot of tools that can that can
kind of deal with eddie's
options especially when in relax so like
we'll see before something picks them up
that does uh all ford four by itself the
hop kick has enough range to pick him up
too oh gosh okay
yeah so if he tries to do an attack that
transitions into relax and then has a
follow-up the hopkin could clean launch
him
all right here we go and that back one
is just gonna harass
uh eddie here we go the follow up he's
gonna get the wall here down two three
no he goes for the back two three three
oh no wow
for that one you have to
go for the wall standing too it's gonna
be a weird range
oh excuse me that
dude he goes for the hopkins that time
but a nice whiff punish here
from callum
first round start from both of them
right
yeah this was very scrambly
back and forth here especially by the
wall that had a weird sidewall situation
for both players
oh there's no punish
that's that's not safe you gotta be able
to punish that down four four
yep let's see what he does
waiting for this opening this
opportunity he's still relying on that
back one is his offense starter
got to watch out for that back dash so
that back dash is killer
and he's starting to notice maybe that
he's not breaking throws yeah that's
definitely looks like one of the biggest
weaknesses we've seen out of calm so far
which is scary of course because you
know
because of the natural movement and the
back dashing it it can be hard to kind
of throw this type of betty so he's
gonna have to be very careful as he
makes his approach all right running two
here what's the mix
that's not like the
on that one that was crazy
i mean he always has blue stuff if you
think about it
oh yeah
the potential for blue stuff it's just a
different kind of blue stuff
again put the back on this time try to
fish
see what callum does here
oh he went straight to relax but again
that was able to deal with it oh caught
him looking yeah you all go up here
hit my relax once i'll go right back
into it
sidewall stun
good adjustment here goes to the low
relax three to four
oh he's gonna have to deal with this
huge life deficit here i'm calum i'm
back dashing
nine
the impatience there then at the counter
hit and the round
right now one round away from taking
that first match we're at the bottom of
the floor no more walls
devils pit one of the few stages with
transitions
right
up there there's a few but it goes to
bigger areas
like uh this should be a building oh
yeah that's right yeah
got him
nice
second hit not ready for it
let's see what he does
oh one more hit could do it oh not for
you
lefty two alive no side roll oh you can
side roll that right always
you can i think it's uh oh i should get
that petrol is it left it's one of the i
think it's left turquoise it's 50 50.
yeah it's 50 50 you guess
but yeah it's not guaranteed but he does
have the other screw from it
which is guaranteed
down forward twos from calum have really
been one of the big
uh factors in this matchup so far onyx
holy moly looking to close it out
oh he got the pick up
jumping three that's not even a jack
move what was that
forward three i don't even know
whatever it was it wasn't the right call
and calum gets the first game because of
it
uh unfortunate for sure yeah very
unfortunate but still able to make
things work out and uh gotta go back to
the drawing board i mean we went down to
the final round there could have gone
either way
but again it's unfortunate you gotta
really uh i guess come on top of those
scrambles and for the most part calum
really really really came out on top uh
defensively i think the play style
kind of
beats out what onyx was doing and onyx
is obviously still struggling to find a
way to get in at least with claudia he
never really found a way to kind of get
in most of the damage that he got uh was
from from whiff punishes right it wasn't
really from pressure so
if if i'm him if he's going to play that
style you might as well use jack that
way at least you have things like the
jackhammer that could deal with certain
things you have an all-purpose slow that
will be a little bit better to use so i
don't know
maybe maybe he's afraid of the back dash
just getting out of that range
could be you know i i do actually agree
is he switching that's the question
oh what do you think yes you're the
master do you think he is
he's switching yeah i'll be devil's
advocate no he's not he's sticking it
out with claudio one hundred
and ten thousand and fifty
percent oh [ __ ] you've got audio yeah
you got it
kinder gym
and he picked kindergarten specifically
for the matchup
i wonder what it is kindergarten must
have us hidden secret we do not know
about
no windows part of japan no windows
[Music]
oh boots boom
the low oh no
i think he should have won a jack
dude countered down for two all day oh
he wasn't ready for that last hit yeah
man
that's unfortunate that's just again
you're showing like
when when he got they start slugging it
out when there's those scrambles you got
to really make sure you come out on top
right now calum is just proving to be
the the better brawler
you're not even going for the extension
like i mean you got to test your
opponent sometimes
because what's the threat the way onyx
is playing there is no threat everything
is mid high
not even getting an opportunity to like
kind of open up his opponent
and that low is not going to do enough
he's going to have to like do do things
like that there you go follow up
he has the wall positioning now but
that's a great block
he got lucky there
yeah i'm really sorry for cal just to
hit the brakes on that combo too oh
wow
he's just outside of rage
he's gonna have to watch out for the
rage drive that one
yeah that one
that one that one hurt ouch round three
again here we go two rounds straight
callum looking to advance
onyx if he loses here he's gonna be out
see what he does no double relax
that's really tricky honestly
sidewall saves lives
but look at the life deficit it may be
too much callum could just kind of run
here but he's still
he's still fighting yeah oh that was a
whiplash
uh but opportunity for onyx last chance
to be honest tournament life on the line
here one hit will do it
there's the break
superman yep
unbelievable he's still alive
he is still breathing honest
can he bring it all the way back
good timing there
oh no punish he's gonna have to be
careful he's gonna have to do something
here
this time go for the knee the mid
the pick up
[Music]
hold for the wall a little bit shorter
the carry the throw works out though
yeah he wearing him down finally got the
throw what's he gonna do here he's gonna
have to watch out
oh my gosh that could have been a wall
splat if he went to the floor
onyx looking really good here
do something no
orbital oh my god so close don't get hit
by ray drive follow him
he's dead
ah
brother unfortunate but hey callum
moving on onyx now out of the tournament
a valiant effort nonetheless
[Music]
valiant effort indeed
but regardless as you mentioned onyx out
of here and you know i was hoping for
the jack dude i really was
me too i thought he was gonna switch but
we're gonna look at some of the action
that we just saw from that matchup as we
get ready for
of course the rest of the tournament
oh this is from uh jupiter here we go
onyx and callum uh which we just saw
here here's the follow up here
pressuring here in this opening matchup
you know the opening matchup could have
gone either way he was able to kind of
take it to the last round there was a
clutch moment there but at the very end
callum was just too solid too strong
really i think the difference here is
onyx really didn't have a way to kind of
find his way in but a big part of it
especially in this last match is those
rage drives those rage drives really
counted uh for cal me made them work and
again not even one of the fastest or
best rate drives in the game but he just
had the timing down no definitely right
the rage drives were hitting uh you know
and he was breaking the throws right we
saw some throws get through but overall
he was breaking up the throws uh the
definitely approach problem with the
claudia was an issue is always gonna be
like the superman punch of the ford ford
four
uh and then even when he had the relax
mix up he wasn't really answering well
uh he had like i think one float combo
one good punish but all in all i think
that the jack to me seemed like it would
have been a better choice uh but
regardless doesn't matter right that's
the way the tournament shakes out we got
fifth place for him there uh and we see
him calum moving on to top four
all right as you guys can see
there uh we're right now in the middle
of region number seven so we are on
september 18th for south africa tomorrow
we have our middle east event but we
have a bunch of events lined up for
online master events throughout the rest
of the month and of course leading into
early october then we switch over to our
regional final events in november we're
starting off with south africa the
region that we're playing in right now
and of course that's going to lead up
into early 2022 as we end it with north
america
exactly and you guys you guys are
getting all these points here uh plus
the dojo events right so make sure you
guys register and be a part of the
leaderboard guys uh you need to register
at the website there on your screen you
guys can see it you guys can type that
in it's a very long url second
esports.bm.ent.net
so that you guys can see your overall
standing from all your dodge events plus
these master events
and of course if you guys are trying to
run your own doge event make sure you
guys send your application soon the
deadline is going to be october 10th so
submit your applications now immediately
that's very soon it's like three weeks
away or something
yeah very soon so make sure again for a
lot of these regions points mean a lot
because again we were looking at what we
had for south africa there was only five
players with points so far so if we can
get more events especially the size of
this i mean 88 people showed up it could
definitely make a difference where
people are trying to qualify in our top
eight with that for a regional final of
course but again we're looking at the
bracket right now we're down to our
final four rip
finally what do you think droopy and
callum go coming up calum just played
his last match with that eddie gordo
jupi he's been mixing it up i mean i
don't know if we're gonna see his fang
or his forum
yes whichever one he feels more
comfortable against the
uh eddie with right but we'll see what
happens there that's the losers
semi-final both those players from south
africa but up at the winners final we
got big daddy mike versus dvk both those
players looked extremely strong earlier
right uh big daddy mike had the crazy
comeback with brian dvk had the
impressive run with miguel so most
likely that's the characters that we're
expecting obviously we're gonna have
uh brian versus miguel for our winners
final here you know classic tekken
characters right you've got uh brian
from tekken 3 miguel from tekken 6 out
here in tekken 7.
man
that that's crazy because i just start
yeah anytime you mention those games i
start thinking about like the
generational differences because you
know tekken 3 was on ps1
right that was a long time ago man i
love that game
but man things have changed quite a bit
coming up
yeah it's uh what is it 20 30 20th 20th
anniversary next year it's got to be
more than that right
it's got be more three was ninety seven
second three was ninety seven so it's
twenty-fifth out of history yeah oh my
gosh
damn we've been playing this game a long
time i've been playing since tekken one
casually in tekken one yeah but i really
got more serious in tekken three and and
of course uh tekken tag one man
our generation
like tekken 2 is one of those games
where everybody played it you know oh
yeah everybody knew about it if you were
anywhere into fighting games you knew
about tekken 3 and you wanted to play it
we used to have this thing in in my
hometown called an arcade it was crazy
that's where we played you had to put
quarters into the machine and we played
this game called tekken 3 and it wasn't
not even on the placement it was before
it was on the playstation it was good
times
i wonder if anyone in the chat had an
arcade have you guys do you guys have
arcades
arcade is that like a like one of those
bowling alleys or something yeah it's
it's it's a while back you know i'm i'm
a little bit older than maybe most of
the chat but i remember vividly putting
in my quarter
you know this great time release was
crazy too because
there would be a new character
oh my gosh
we are we are blessed we are blessed
nowadays where we could just easily
unlock characters and they're instantly
available but back then you had to wait
over time for new characters to unlock
it's kind of the same for them you know
they call it dlc now
ah yeah
yeah maybe yeah okay yeah i'll give it
that yeah it releases after a lot of
time and you got to pay for it
we're in the winner's final let's go
to three
uh this is the first of three because
this winter's final it's gonna be
whoever gets the three matches oh man
damn arcades
sorry i had to phrase it like that but
you know you never know some people
might not know so we gotta talk about it
anyways we're gonna go into the matchup
here
this is a race to three first of three
matches big daddy mike versus dvk this
is the match that we were just talking
about brian fury
brian fury from tekken 3 vs miguel from
tekken 6.
he's trying to taunt that upper or maybe
try taunt four two one four or something
no i want to give people the benefit of
the doubt they're doing content uppers
uh honestly i think right now my
favorite to win the tournament is dbk
but big daddy mike
turned things around against calum
earlier
here we go
oh
damn i love that hit
oh no off axes combo whips big daddy
mike ready for it gets the launch
expands the raid drive just to confirm
the kill
yep made it count
oh northern cross nice punish there not
safe
see what he does here ooh
if he converted on that that would have
been sick
with the with the with the vengeance
here looking to come back
see what he does
and miguel you know miguel i feel like
is one of those characters that doesn't
get enough respect you know we we rarely
see him in competitive play but he's
definitely a character that can that can
duke it with the best of them
yeah miguel definitely beats me up
though man since tekken 6.
[Music]
here we go pushing towards the wall here
one more he could do it goes for the
shoulder lean oh my gosh
i rarely see that move hit but it's
beautiful whenever i see it because he
goes woohoo
he's happy
most rifler just run up and do it you
know
yeah
that was sick
and it was oh
nice has the wall here do it oh he went
yeah yeah gotta respect
follow up here
let's see what he goes for still could
do with the pressure he went for the
interrupt
i thought he was gonna punish it yeah
running punch here the follow with the
lows do it again oh my gosh i would have
ducked the fourth one damn
oh god i've been missing him
down dab check i love it
all right dvk staying alive in this
first game here
ready to duck it but gets back kicked
right after man that was such a good
option
nice gets to grab here see what it is he
has the wall positioning as well this
could be bad probably he might be dead
he might be dead boy yes
easy so we keep it simple the perfect
for big daddy mike to close out game
number one as i said he's my favorite
right
yeah i mean that sequence at the very
end is very convincing because you got
to remember that taunt
it guarantees if the taunt hits it
guarantees the follow-up and there's a
number of moves that brian can do
but if you see that that taunt hit that
causes a move follow-up to be guaranteed
you know there's a
if you want to be amazing and do
something crazy you could do the jet
upper which is of course frame perfect
double double frame perfect because you
have to execute it fast enough but
there's a number of other moves you can
do to just even get the knock down but
it was great stuff there good good
presence of mind knowing that he would
tech roll and put him into that
unblockable position yeah in that
situation when they have one pixel left
and if you hit anything you're going to
win the game like you don't go for
anything more than that if you are
you're trying to style on them right
uh that dvk is a very strong competitor
so i would not try to give them any
chances like you get the thought you're
doing the most simple thing to get the
damage get it done close it out
yeah the good times anyways we'll see
um going back to the drawing board maybe
because this is an extended set of
course players if they lose have the
option to switch characters right it's
either switch characters or they get to
pick the stage so i'm wondering here
what's going on in his mind what is he
going to do how is he going to kind of
change things up or is he just going to
stick to the same character
i don't know anything about dbk but i'm
going to assume he's a character
loyalist
you think so you think miguel players
are
yeah i think yoshi and yoshi players and
miguel players are i'll see
not gonna stick to miguel he's gonna
definitely switch to regular gin
he wasn't even a real miguel he's going
to gin
miguel's my third area bro here comes my
gin
all right
well let's see if jin kazama is able to
do it
if gin kazama can do it maybe steve
kazama could do it
i really thought that he was gonna stick
to miguel i really liked this miguel i
think that it was fine
uh yeah but let's see i wonder i wonder
what the logic is in picking ginger
maybe he wants to parry some of these
brian attacks
i honestly don't know but i mean jin is
a good character so we'll see you
we might have our first electric of the
day
huh let's see what happens
oh
gotta be careful so far the gin pick i
mean he needs to clutch it out it hasn't
paid off yet
that's an opportunity but again he does
have some flexibility with the lows
times the wasting he's gonna have to
react he'll sweep into the orbital wow
round two you gotta be careful you gotta
be careful
nice demon pog start things off here
big daddy mike again confident there
with that three plus four
controlling that open space here there's
an electric
sometimes you got to do it just keep
them honest
see what he does here again with the
demon paw
again he still needs to i feel like he
needs to kind of establish himself here
with the lows
there you go there's one way to do it
do it again oh he he has a splat
oh that was enough damage it's okay it's
okay
i mean with that lively there it's
really hard to make a comeback from that
situation dbk on the scoreboard again
wow
demon says one plus two the follow up
here
let's see what he does does he get the
wall he does oh he missed it standing to
the savage sword he got greedy
yo
that hit that would have been disaster
but luckily slightly mistimes the back
four
man i love the in and out movement from
dvk right now good life but the hatchets
are going to come
big daddy mike no stranger making
comebacks has really oh
he should be dead caledonia should be
dead oh man that was crazy anyways good
stuff here for big daddy mike here
looking to extend his lead he wants to
go up 2-0 but dvk really needs this he
doesn't want to be in a situation where
he has to win three straight games
oh oh oh here we go
all right standing jab savage sword
keeps him at the wall the spring kick
able to get the momentum off of him
good punish
see what he does here
again looking for that opening looking
for an opportunity oh he tried a hot
kick
oh
yeah he wasn't he didn't have the wall
there
he could have changed things if he did
have it
and again ending with the taunt into a
follow-up and right now big daddy mike
is up 2-0 here in our winner's finals
one more match could seal the deal where
he'll earn himself a spot in our grand
finals
but right now i mean
you got to think about it what are you
going to do because you're in a
situation where you're down 2-0 you have
to switch
to a character and you're going to be
stuck with a character you have to win
three straight
three straight if you want to advance
i think he should have stuck to miguel
right for the whole set but the gin my
issue with this gin is like he plays a
kind of miguel like he doesn't play like
a mission
you know he doesn't he doesn't have the
whiff punches like an electric or like a
dash electric right yeah and i feel like
if you want to switch to a gin
especially when you're talking about the
winners final of a big tournament uh you
gotta have those electrics ready you
know you can't play gin uh the basic
non-mishima style which you know i feel
like a lot of players forget that you
can play a lot of these missionary
characters without that wave dash and
they can still be effective but once you
get at the top of the competition you
gotta have all the pieces of the puzzle
right you have to have the wave dash you
gotta have everything there and right
now that looks like it's lacking
yeah you gotta be on point uh every step
of the way i mean
i think uh learning for opportunities
and making sure that you take advantage
of them is super important if you guys
are just tuning in you guys are watching
the tekken online challenge for south
africa we're in the middle of our
winners final right now between uh big
daddy mike and dvk mozambique vs kenya
is gonna stick to gin
this is a decision because he has he has
to stick to jin the entire time
the entire time
here we go
maybe he maybe he needs some warm-up
maybe he's feeling himself
i mean there were a few situations here
one of the unfortunate ones too is when
he went for the parry into the punch
series but then of course it got blocked
and he got jet upward he and big daddy
mike was ready for it
yeah that's uh definitely one of those
things you gotta find and that's been
working out right forward forward to zen
one plus two uh that like is like a
weird setup like you can just duck and
launch him and it's not really a good
strong midfault that he's gonna kill you
with but
big daddy mike has been caught by that a
couple times already so dvk definitely
recognizing that and pulling the trigger
on capitalizing on it early yeah you
have to actively be blocking if you try
to do anything else even in neutral
you're going to get launched
ooh he tried to sidestep he could have
sidestepped
what he does here
not enough to kill got to be careful yep
he does such a good job of hitting the
brakes right i feel like that's been one
of the differences that i've seen
between big daddy mike and his opponent
so far today uh end of round situation
he just seems to be more close than
everyone
[Music]
all right let's see what he does
oh
duck in there you got to be able to kind
of get those openings and right now dvk
is not looking good big counter hit for
big daddy mike see what he does oh damn
he wanted it he is trying he's trying to
make me rip off my shades rip off my
headset and scream around my house at
six in the morning that's what he wants
for
that i mean i'll do it i'll do it he's
up oh you're he's big chilling dude nice
hopkins let's get a noise complaint
let's do it
let's get it
here we go kelsey oh no the get up kick
he's looking to close it out he should
be able to get it here bob there it is
big daddy mike one round away from
securing a spot in our grand finals will
he be able to do it or will dvk be able
to fight back
the uk is not looking too bad you know
these were close rounds so far in this
third match
it's always the end around situation
holy mod kick that was from around the
world that was crazy brian was facing
the wrong direction when that started i
feel like yo if he doesn't get the tan
jet upright don't count to me
it don't count to me you better do it
oh he doesn't even need
yeah he definitely did it because man
that was clean
oh yeah very clean big daddy mike going
on
two the grand finals guaranteeing
himself a top to finish here
congratulations big daddy mike uh the
brian fury looking good so far man
looking good dvk down to loser bracket
loses final for him uh but you know that
was a little odd to me you know that he
didn't stick to miguel i feel like the
miguel was pretty good and i feel like
honestly when you look back at the whole
set miguel did best uh compared to the
two games with jin dvk might have
another chance though you know he's
going to be obviously uh put down into
the loser bracket where he's going to be
waiting in our losers finals if he's
able to win that against one of our two
other players in the losers bracket
he'll have another shot
so
again strategy going into this
for you to be able to lose and be
eliminated from the german you have to
lose two times so far he's only lost one
so he still has another chance
all right
let's take a look-see here boys and
girls uh this is the replay back at the
match and you know that miguel the way
things started it was looking pretty
close you know but it really seemed like
end of the round situations like big
daddy mike's always finding the answer
keeping it simple there
taunt down four or two to close it out
uh and as you mentioned the gin was
doing all right ready to start off going
back and forth uh but there man the size
of one uh
the damage dude
end of round situation again yep
getting those toss when he needs them
the tenticular fortitude
is so strong
i like how slow you set it to enunciate
every bit of it you got to you gotta
have to
yeah you can't put yourself in a
situation where it's like what did he
just say what do you say fortitude yeah
take it home use it
yes i got it i may have to borrow that
one
but we do see him moving on to the grand
finals big daddy mike here comes the
bracket for you guys big daddy mike one
step closer to closing out that
championship dude getting the
championship of course dbk down in the
losers final waiting for the winner of
our next match which will be the loser
semis with droopy versus callum droopy
of course we've seen with both feng wei
and horung in this tournament so far
aurong didn't get it done that was his
winner's final run or winning sammy's
run uh and then switch to fang
undefeated thanks so far in the winner's
top eight
he might hook us up you know he might be
able to give us a third character who
knows maybe droopy has something else in
his arsenal but uh calum you know he's
been using eddie the entire way uh and
he's been making it work i feel like uh
it'll be an interesting matchup if we
see fenway versus eddie just because uh
both characters or both players have the
option to kind of just back up off their
opponent with the reverse campus up the
back kenpo and the back dash so it's
going to be kind of like a war of
attrition between the two of who can get
each other to whiff
no definitely i
i hope that we see the fang way i think
you know but obviously he's gonna know
best which character he prefers against
eddie uh and i think from calum it just
seems like he's gonna stick 100 with
eddie the whole way through right of
course i've said that about every person
and they've all switched characters so
far so maybe callum has someone else for
us but i feel like any players in
particular
are
more they have more loyalty to their
characters you know
like when did you actually start using
eddie even mark was that like your first
or second character king king has been
my main character since second two uh i
started
seriously using eddie in second four i
think okay so not even [ __ ] three for
eddie for you
oh yeah i did i messed around with him
and played with her and match kick
buttons with him but i didn't really try
to learn him learn him right
but i i wish i did i wish i did in
second three because he had a crazy
command side step it was it was nuts do
people still
have that like any stigma about him
mashing kick buttons like i remember in
tekken3d was like that but i mean do you
think that second tag two didn't help
man tekken tag two didn't help with
double capos it's true i used to
terrorize people online um
by not even looking at the screen and
just holding forward and hitting kicks
it works sometimes
it works
no i i i'm pretty sure eddie and law
and huarang have that stigma of hitting
kick buttons and doing cool things right
sometimes that's empowering for people
especially at the lower level when they
don't know what they're doing and
sometimes that's enough to get you
hooked is like you do something cool you
remember that kind of stuff and it makes
you want to learn how to play the game
that is whole that's real rap i don't
know how many people in the chat if if
that was your situation where you fell
in love with tekken just by seeing cool
moves by matching some buttons that
that's i think that's a byproduct of
excellent design at least at that level
right
of course a lot of you guys are here for
the competitive side of things and
that's obviously much different because
you look under a different microscope
but they wouldn't even be watching this
if they didn't think this stuff looked
cool you know like you never know first
place sometimes you go on twitter just
want to see seconds
but they didn't
hear like oh you know this guy arsenash
uh he's a real good looking dude come
check him out competing you should like
throw them like that you know
i feel like they saw the thumbnail on
twitch and they saw your hair and
they're like you know what i'm in
i'm here what conditioner does that guy
use i'm watching competitive technique
what's his conditioner
here we go
oh he's gonna push towards the wall here
it's interesting that he picked kwarang
right yeah cause i honestly thought bang
might have been maybe the better choice
here same
yeah but you know
i gotta say eddie is really good against
warren in my opinion
why is that he has a lot of just because
there's certain
depending on how the huang plays if he
gets really really cheeky and tries to
go for certain mix-ups there's a lot of
options that eddie has where he can
evade whether it's down back one plus
two back one plus two or just ducking
into while setting one there's a lot of
damage there and also there's little
gaps where he can back three counter hit
i see
so eddie has a lot of opportunity
depending on how the huang plays
but that kind of goes into with eddie's
modus operandi is like you know he's
either going to backdash or wait
defensively for his opportunity yep
here's the follow-up back 2-3-3
yeah i feel like fang's obviously strong
in this match see what he does he goes
for the mix-up
doesn't catch him
oh close it out nice nice clean up there
with the down four
and this guy's first to two games only
first and two games lose the semifinals
low parries are good and as you can see
this is the weakness of groupies horn
right you'll see a lot of his lows are
really getting him killed he doesn't
have that problem when he's fang though
right it's his down three fours and even
like the scan slows that they're like
lost or what cost them but there we go
mixing it up with the mid this time
but weird combo ender choice there
doesn't matter he's got some damage
oh ceo
if he didn't have the power quest he
would have been launched
but again he has to be careful that
power question is not safe
yeah wall's not broken behind count not
a lot of facebook counter hit down
forward two will seal the first game
from three rounds straight
just the natural play style from callum
was just too much for that character
matchup and the way that uh his opponent
was approaching that huarang and droopy
i didn't think would have a good fit
there just trying to break down his
opponent or take the advantage over
there i really think he needs to switch
to fenway to make this work again
because this is a shorter set a race to
two right
man maybe he should have started faying
from the get-go because i mean hua rang
definitely did not work there was no
situation in that matchup where i saw he
had the advantage at all right
and you know i saw the chat uh you know
talking about my criticism of his horror
i'm just saying that specifically the
match we've seen him lose with this
horrong right the way he's lost is that
the opponents have a good read on his
down three fours like that specifically
like we saw uh dvk continuously duck and
launched with miguel and now we're
seeing it look back at this that he got
low paired and ducked a lot as well
right so yeah uh it's just that seems to
be the weakness of his horron
specifically
so
now you know with his fang when we saw
that he didn't have that issue right um
we'll see what happens if he tries the
fang right here but i think he he might
stick it out with horan here i'm not
sure
i'd switch i honestly i would switch i
feel like
he couldn't get any off and started and
if you're not doing that with juan
you're not doing anything
agreed
he didn't go for the pressure on too
right like he keeps you guessing
constantly
oh
he's sticking to it here we go he picks
brimstone and fire
all right all right
here we go sticking a wrong here
he's gonna have to definitely mix things
up
uh better right like and he's gotta
watch out for the loads like the dalty
f4 has definitely gotten killed in the
last set
definitely brimstone of fire
no transition infinite stage which is
kind of a good thing for him here
i don't got to worry about callum
dashing forever nice there's a factory
to start it off big
combo there peacekeeper in between the
follow up here he gets the wall mix up
see what he does
hey
nice good start doesn't get the launch
punish that back to be not safe of
course launch punishable
another one nope too far
now what's he gonna do this is where
it's big
oh is he he's putting himself in
situations where he gets punished for
certain things
yep he has to make sure that he keeps
the pressure on but also stays safe
enough
yeah one of those characters that has
just you know a ton of options right so
you can you can often play him safer but
you gotta take some risks at some point
uh but choosing when to take the risk is
the question and there it is down before
it gets ducked and full launched
seems inevitable right
oh yeah
that's for sure i mean there's a lot of
options that he has again but it's all
about how you approach the initial hit
and how you get into that up close game
nice
and again you remember we were talking
about this before calum was not breaking
throws in any of the other matchups as
well so this might be an opportunity
maybe jupi
kind of realized here but it might be
too little too late he does have rage
this is gonna hurt the drive nice
from groupie for sure
fight i'm sorry from calum for sure yeah
jupy though finally getting around he
needed that definitely needed that let's
go ruby nice whip punch at the back
three four
oh and this is gonna hurt
hey
what's the mix
tried to back one plus two out of there
again with the evasive attacks oh what
is he doing he's trying to whip
punishment up through the people's four
not gonna happen and that's one of the
moves i yeah you don't see enough
he had the duck too
oh caliber oh no don't let him come back
with this little help oh my gosh he was
airborne yep not much in the wall
yes man there was a little perry there
that would have been disaster but droopy
got to leave now it's got to be building
a little bit of confidence nice
nice block punish i should say oh yeah
that is fast enough because that is what
negative 18.
here we go it does have a slight
pushback so sometimes punishers can be
inconsistent but eddie
of course
was right there got it eddie's guy he's
got enough range
yep he has long legs for some reason
maybe he likes kicking
yep
oh boy
lost that time that one is out of
nowhere right that's a bit of hallmark
of groupies playstyle those plasma plays
they just come out of nowhere but here
we go it's set point for callum right
now wins this round and it's over
groupies out of here
droopy could do it though all he needs
is this round and then he'll have
another chance three four
okay
launched
big damage here early oh my gosh he
wasn't ready
he's testing him and look at that i'm
out of there oh no he couldn't down back
four into screw
not able to do it hey has another
opportunity
oh oh
this is big he does have rage
5050
the lows have not been favorable for him
at all telling you
uh with horung at least right
uh because horan you know he goes to
stance and it's a little bit more
predictable uh but there you have it you
know uh groupie gonna be out of the
tournament at fourth place calum moving
on to top three uh which of course means
that calum one match away from getting
his run back against the person who said
down here in the first place so yeah
we'll be interesting to see if you can
get it back there but nice try from
groupie uh stuck with the horn the whole
way through that time obviously doesn't
work out from goes down 2-0
uh but
uh it you know it's it's all calum right
now and his eddie has been ridiculous
from the moment we saw oh yeah so we
have our top three confirmed uh our last
three players three different countries
from the region we have dvk in kenya
callum in south africa and of course big
daddy mike in mozambique
very very cool see the country
represented here but let's take a look
back at the match here uh this is the
first one right and you can see the
round count here callum in the lead
uh is it gonna be a counter dump or two
it is a counter hit down four two that's
one of the the besties that count does
too when he's playing just neutral with
eddie and then here down to the wire
what's gonna be low parry incoming there
it is
if you just went for the mid it would
have been all over there it would have
been all over he had the wall and
everything
yeah very it's kind of a risky situation
when you're calling that situation but
he was looking at the fuzzy low prairie
and still guard mid again right that's
why he didn't commit to a block in that
situation
a smart choice from callum uh gets it
done moves on top through the tournament
and he's been looking good as i
mentioned throughout the day right his
one loss was to big daddy mike and that
was probably the craziest match we've
seen here down the wire back and forth
the whole way through uh but to get back
there he's got to go through dvk first
right so dvk 18 with the miguel and jen
now so you know we know it's going to be
eddie right at least i know i feel like
i know it's going to be eddie
no i'm pretty sure it'll be eddie as
well but again the question is i think
dvk is going to probably start off with
miguel right
that seems to be his character choice he
only picked jin as a counterpick when he
started losing in that opening match so
i feel like i'm confident that he'll
stick with miguel again
i hope so unless unless he feels like
miguel is really bad against eddie or
something you know then he might be jin
right
yeah i mean jin
is really good against eddie too so
i don't know there's there's a lot of
options here but again and it's all
about how it's played because
the the key difference between eddie
eddie has i think a lot of shortcomings
and a lot of matchups but if the eddy
player is able to kind of backdash and
control the spacing then it's a it
doesn't matter because he's he's
outpacing and out spacing against his
opponent
but that's the thing is like will he be
able to do that will he be able to
defensively
put himself in that in that in that
situation so we'll see but from what
i've seen so far we haven't really seen
um
pressuring offense from dbk either
i think his miguel
i think his miguel actually has a lot of
good pressure so i hope i'm really
hoping that we see the miguel for the
rest of the turnaround dbk
ultra are we are we taking a break right
now i could i couldn't
gotcha uh real quick before we go into
break guys i want to talk about some of
the t-shirts that we have available from
the team over at 10-0 you guys can check
out the good ass tekken king and law
shirts which are now back in stock you
guys can scan that qr code on the screen
or go to the website 10-0 gg slash merch
the link is also being shown uh
throughout the chat as well so make sure
you guys take advantage of this deal we
got the blue and the black we also have
the black and the yellow for law which
is back in stock now for a limited time
once they are gone they are gone so make
sure you guys check them out uh 10-0 gg
merch
exactly and it's the first time that
these guys have come back in right they
were the first shirts that were sold
they sold out before now they're backs
if you guys want them now's the time all
right don't don't say that we didn't
tell you we didn't warn you all right
once they're gone they're god good luck
oh yeah
of course you guys can also follow us
online on all the different accounts
it's tekken for twitter twitch and
facebook of course be any esports on
twitter and also on youtube where you
can catch all of the action that you may
have missed today or in past events as
well so make sure you guys check us out
on all those different accounts that you
see on our screen
but anyways before we get into our top
three we are going to be taking a short
break so make sure you guys stick to it
and hang in there as we come back with
more tekken online challenge
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the tarnished
will soon return
guided by grace
once lost
the golden order is broken
to its core
foul tarnished
in search of the elden ring
emboldened by the flame of ambition
someone must extinguish
thy flame
they will fight
and they will die
in an unending curse
power is a champion
or a lord
a lowly tarnished
playing as a lord
i command thee
brandish the elden ring
for all of us
it's not just our power
it's all about powers working as a team
don't underestimate me
here goes
[Music]
[Applause]
we have to work together
[Music]
[Applause]
focus
connect your minds and become one
use the red strings to save the world
you two handle the front while i take
the back
don't bother resisting i will obtain the
red strings
[Music]
[Music]
pretty fancy place they got here
harmony and coexistence
between the renins and the danons
should you need my skills on the
battlefield all i care for is
maintaining peace
i'm captain kisara of the el dominancia
god
from now on when i fight
i fight to protect my dream well this
crew just gets bigger and bigger
the renin's
seems the rumors you were running with
them were true
been looking for you
get the hell out of my realm
this is tannen's realm and it's ours
understand
is it over
it's only just begun
welcome back everyone to the tekken
online challenge south africa we are
getting very close of course to the end
of the tournament but we just saw some
amazing videos from some of the new
games and uh some of the games out now
from bandai namco entertainment tales of
veriz just came out last week uh it said
pre-order in that trailer but again the
game is out now if you guys want to
check that out available on all
platforms and i'm super excited for
eldon ring you know i'm a big uh from
software fan a big souls fan so i can't
wait for that game to come out rip how
you feeling yeah elton ring i mean i
think that game for me specifically uh i
really like the art style like it's a
little bit more vibrant than the older
from soccer games you know so it's uh
closer to how the new demon souls is
actually on ps5 even right i love that i
love that game yeah i can't wait
but of course that's going to be coming
out early next year so i'm looking
forward to it
but we are here in our top three of this
tournament guys if you guys are tuning
us it's been pretty crazy but of course
before we get there a huge shout out to
astro the official headset and mix amp
of the tekken online challenge uh shout
outs of course to azure supporting all
things tekken uh throughout everywhere
basically so yes
now guys we also have the leaderboard to
see where these players are standing so
far
obviously this is the first time we're
doing this out here right they also have
dojo points but you see the leaderboard
so far groupie in the lead 195. uh i
didn't realize just doing that well so
do grouping going out here at fourth
place is a little bit of a surprise uh
x-star and onyx are tied below that at
70 then you got ongobunga with 45
mimosas as well uh then you got dax with
40 and calum with just 11 there and
frost with 10. but calum now in the top
three that's gonna be huge right it's
gonna skyrocket him up oh
yeah this of course does not take into
account of course the rest of the places
so this will be updated of course after
the tournament but of course you can
expect the guys that are in top three to
skyrocket and jump in this top eights uh
placings for south africa
exactly so
groupie looking good here even with this
fourth place finish uh calum of course
gonna fly up to dvk big daddy mike not
even in that top eight but after today
uh you can pretty much guarantee that
big daddy mike's gonna be in there uh as
well as probably dvk depending on if you
can get past calum here oh no they're
definitely going to be in the in the
standings and again the top point
standings is what gets you into the
regional finals so hopefully these guys
continue to play and continue to battle
it out but
uh we were talking about losers finals
we have of course uh three players left
uh dvk and callum it's gonna be
we think it's gonna be miguel going up
against eddie um i mean dvk also use gin
so it'll be interesting to see what
matchups we have in play
right and uh personally i just feel like
dbk's miguel is very impressive we'll
see
how he feels about the eddie matchup
this is the one place where you kind of
know the character you're going up
against on the other hand of that you
got big daddy mike who's only used brian
so far as well right oh yeah but we'll
see i think the miguel would be a good
choice here i feel like miguel at least
in the parts of the world that i've seen
is still an underused character right
underutilized for sure right so whenever
you see a player that's good with that
character they tend to do well in terms
like top three finishes because the
character is good the player is good and
people aren't as familiar with it it's
like a great combination of things to
come together for you
uh but miguel definitely not an easy
character to use like i've tried to use
that character i it just doesn't make
sense to me you know my brain doesn't
click with it uh so shout out to all the
miguel players out there making it work
oh yeah
and speaking of miguel he is using
miguel so it is the matchup that we kind
of expected going into this
and this is uh since it's losers final
it's gonna be a race to three
three wins and you are in the grand
finals but only one of these two players
will make it loser will get third place
and we are going to the dragon's nest
oh yeah it was guys to touch the floor
man cuz that's when he's about to get
crazy he's gonna start breakdancing nice
counter hit down four three to up three
he's just checking the surface he's like
oh yeah i can break dance on this yep i
could do it on this
like oh can i back dash on this yup
let's go
like you said that i was in my head i'll
take all brake dancers or like can i do
flare so i'm like oh yeah no he's gonna
back dash
oh yeah
i mean look at that shuffle he's just
going dude he's
this looks like is this game broken
what's happening
he's dancing all over the place oh my
did you see that that was crazy what uh
that was eddie oh he dropped ender oh
okay never mind he's good he's good yeah
uh i feel like calum
is confident in the matchup the way he's
moving it's like he's he's been there
done that yeah and that that desperation
hop kick from dvk at the end didn't
really give do many favors right in the
back here what are you gonna do oh my
gosh i don't think he was ready for that
exactly i'll just say i guess these
characters that have these weird spring
kicks would they end up battered to you
if you block it you got to be ready to
like destroy them right take like 50
percent of health because you can get a
full watch on them
bro callum looks so
prepared for this okay never mind
yeah as soon as i said that man it's the
curse thing that they talk about that
commentator's curse
rickster claims it's not real
uh
i i think it's different too especially
when if you
do commentary but you also play
like i don't know how you feel do cause
like your curse the curse that you did
to feed the ex recently is kind of real
i i even i heard about that i wasn't
talking
i felt like i cursed him as soon as i
said it i was like oh boy oh
why did i say that
all right here we go he's going to keep
him there dvk
has a huge life lead here and then calum
right now he can't really back that's
too much he has the wall right behind
him
but he's got that right
that's it we haven't seen that sweep yet
so far in the competition so right now
dvk pulling off to the lead callum what
you gonna do that was actually such a
risky choice when you think about it
right
like yeah sleep there get a big life
lead why would you write that because i
got launched and you know this is again
depending on the different players in
different regions we see a different
type of
tone of the match in a different type of
pacing uh more often than not we've seen
a lot of lows at the end of rounds we we
see ankles getting hurt
and some plus low prairies and low ducks
yeah
here we go nice punish there with the
jabs
man callum is just in and out
we've beautiful
and he hit him with that
big launch to follow up here he's gonna
get the wall of the back two three three
one more hit close it out
rage drive
takes his turn back see what he does
this is important gotta watch out times
are waiting oh my god that was so sick
and just because of that he is gonna win
the match
what a hop kick
that was impressive that is a
beautifully placed top kick right there
that's what i like to see very nicely
done dvk getting it done the first game
with miguel here slow and easy is the
way i want to hop kick tonight
that was good stuff good hop kick
and just like that
first match again this is a race to
three
still not over by a long shot but i feel
like callum the way he was kind of
playing and moving he was in cruise
control for a long time but again
clutching it out is another thing
he felt he felt comfortable with the way
he was moving in and out but it wasn't
enough it wasn't enough and that's the
thing is like sometimes you got to play
uh and like yeah back dashing see back
cashing is good right
you know what what's the bad thing about
back dashing
it doesn't do damage that's very true no
damage it doesn't do damage until you
get a whiff punish right yeah
which he has shown that he can do he can
do it right
but again it's just part of the puzzle
yeah the other thing i really like about
his back dash is it seems like a lot of
his opponents they get really flustered
by it like they're like dude he's not
doing i have to go do something you know
and they come in and they they just put
too much in line these boom counter it
down four or two you know so yeah i feel
like that's a big deal here you got to
be patient uh when you go against an
eddy player that's just back dashing all
day don't give them that opportunity
because you know they're waiting for it
yeah that's one of the strengths though
i feel like for eddie as well is like
sometimes you want to frustrate your
opponent kind of annoy them and then
have them kind of go for their bigger
longer advancing attacks but that's like
prime real estate for you to throw out
the counter hit down forward to throw
out the counter at back three three it's
uh it kind of fits in with the play
style and
as a player you have to
kind of like buckle down and like not
fall for it
have that patience
anyways we are going to violet systems
this is one of the longer stages at
least on one side
uh and we'll see how it plays out here
yeah definitely one of my favorite
stages
it's the combos for me
did the combos do it yeah this is the
combats
i mean you can think about a lot of
mochajin man
i don't know man combat and bokugen
that that's a that's a tough one
bokugen's mother jeans in the game he's
like a
an item that you could add on to
characters oh please
he's also a character panel
he's in there i think the other i think
that is my current uh
character panel actually there you go
now calm off the good lead here in game
two round one
keep it solid
nice
nice go for the size of three plus four
unable to get anything out of it calum
was looking really good obviously with a
little bit more room to work here but
still has the benefit of walls
let's see what he does nice a ford four
and this is something that we haven't
really seen from him in the spacing game
so far the l4 has a little bit better
range than some of the other pokes that
he's been using but again he has to be
kind of aware just on how on its use
nice side support
yeah eddie doesn't really have the best
lows he has a lot of them i'll say that
he has a lot of lows
a lot of scary lows but not the best
lows when it comes to like breaking down
your opponent
yeah there's just more for the noise but
look at the punish there
that while standing one
all right good knock down there from dbk
he still got likely here time
still plenty
i like the way he's sidestepping
readjusting this is gonna hurt
not gonna kill but one more sequence
could do it
dbk he has the rage drive
if he gets that low
oh wow i didn't expect that that came
out of nowhere that was nice
uh but calum good defense holds on
boots and he's gonna get the wall too
what's he gonna do here oh the splat
oh yes
uh-huh the follow-up here gets the head
noggin
hit him with the diddy bop what's he
gonna do that pressure he went for the
power cush with no light
yeah oh
man
maybe he got too much of a of a flow
there
uh just what he's used to because i mean
it's a great move to use by the wall
right but you need to have life that's
the the the weakness of the power
crushes yes it can go through moves but
it also still takes life
exactly
uh but calum answering back there with
the eddy uh yeah kind of expected it you
know i honestly thought the way the
first game was going that callum was
going to get that one as well right so
uh the fact that he even up here not
unexpected but
uh we'll see how this whole set plays
out i'm really curious because this
first three it's a long set there's
still a chance that dvk could switch
characters here uh but i think so far
the miguel's working out what do you
think went wrong for him in that second
game
it just i i think it was a combination
of things it's he got impatient and you
know a lot of what we saw in the first
game you know he he clutched it out and
his clutch was not present at all
there and he just put himself in a lot
of situations where it was interesting
because you know like eddie's back was
to the wall a lot of the time right
because of whether it was back dashing
or just combo spacing or whatever but he
didn't attack he didn't get in and one
of the things that we saw early on is he
went for a lot of those lows and this
time obviously getting blocked getting
launched with the while standing one
three i feel like it's a matter of
timing and also using threatening mids
by the wall because you know miguel has
a ton of mids that could wall splat as
well he has a very
good i think arsenal of mid attacks that
can be very threatening but it's all
about using him i mean he hasn't i mean
if you think about he hasn't been using
a lot of moves at all
yeah he's been trying to play the same
kind of patient gameplay but
uh doing the same thing like that
against eddie when he's got such a
better back dash
uh you know it's a hard game to play for
sure and i think miguel definitely
excels at a closer range game
so you know closing in on eddie is going
to be one of the question marks and as
you mentioned if anything's going to be
back dashing all day he's going to hit
the wall this stage here a little bit
larger a lot more angles to work with
which could help in
helping eddie screw up his rage art and
make him go the wrong direction we'll
see if that comes into play
maybe it will maybe we'll we'll see
anyways they're gonna go right into it
tied up one a piece right now again a
longer set a race to three between these
two
we're in the forbidden temple grounds
here
as these players battle it out and i
like what i'm seeing here so right now
callum is kind of actually fighting up
close he does have a slight life lead
but now dvk starting to open him up
there's a running boot to the face
yeah chop those ankles
boo
the power chris i got plenty of hell
this time
yeah made it count and right now dbk
taking that first round i like what i'm
saying too because he's also using the
throws to kind of pressure and we saw
early on oh my gosh
that that was the right thing to do but
it wasn't close enough
[Music]
does uh
miguel's hopkin get there on relax
it can't hit and relax okay but you have
to be close enough closer right yeah
oh here we go
interesting goes for that load just get
some damage
yeah this up close game man
ever the aggressor right now man it's
been paying off so far there's a low the
follow up here into the mid attack dvk
is
taking control right now this is the way
he needed to play back then like you
can't back dash with the when the wall's
there what are you gonna do
nice nice that was a good block i mean
it could have been a bad punish right
there too yep
oh no
yeah and you know that he knew he was
getting right in front of him but still
late there
and now callum
good life lead here down two rounds but
you can't count him out we saw the crazy
stuff he had earlier
oh my gosh everything's hitting
the block of the lawn he's dead he's
dead
yeah sparks
was short do the rage out early so you
get less scaling on it should be enough
to have to kill them boom there's the
round for calum hey can i uh interest
you in some cutscene would you like to
watch i love some
give me more all right how are you for
the power crush good stuff i mean you
have to go for a faster move if you want
to get the float there
the power crush can activate pretty fast
from the handstand position
[Music]
uh-huh there we go he hasn't used that
either right the 3-2
[Music]
yeah which i think is a great tool
overall yeah
gotta test your opponents here's the
follow-up
dvk again
has the wall positioning
oh
nice
ford ford for follow-up oof
oh he's getting confidence right now
what's with the grab look at pulls it
out of here
yo look at that very dominant rounds the
aggression is really what to come over
it's a kind of take control of the
matchup and just like that callum is in
trouble i gotta say it straight up right
now before we get into the next match
callum cannot play like that i don't
know what the difference is here other
than maybe the aggression from dvk but
calum really needs to start fighting
back and there's a lot of tools where he
can do so
i feel like using eddie's jabs is key
for that he needs to start using the
jabs yeah right now like dvk he's
getting in right like in the previous
games you know he was playing the range
game he's trying to play that game with
eddie but obviously that's where eddie
wants to play at right yep uh where
miguel wants to play at he wants to be
in your face and i think cal i think
that dvk did a much better job of
staying close to calm that entire game
there uh and anytime he'd run up he's
like i need to run up and do like down
forward one uh you know you saw a couple
of rounds end that way uh because he's
opening up with these lows now too so
you know you really got calum guessing
here and i totally agree with you i
think the jabs need to come out as like
a keep out tool you know even if it's
just like the downford one one or just
the one two uh whichever one it may be
right uh he's done a good job like sized
at four to keep out uh you know those
kind of keeper tools are working but i
feel like he wasn't doing enough keep
out tools uh side support might be good
too because you know as a keep out tool
if he gets hop kicked or something it's
not really gonna be too much damage
because it might not be a full float
that's true it's all about the range and
how you kind of utilize things but we're
in open stage
and calum decides to go for the infinite
azure
but yeah you know you know that is i
mean it's it's purely for backing up
oh yeah
let's see if he can force that gameplay
on dbk and keep him out this time that's
gonna be the question cause that was the
difference in game three but dvk up two
games to one here just needs one more to
go to the grand finals and get his run
back let's see girl you look good once
you back that dash up
take that dash off
yup here we go start it off
[Music]
oh counter hit down forward two he was
waiting for that opportunity
this time getting the big launch to
follow up now he can run
sometimes i run
oh counted oh my gosh going back the
other way oh he lost
it what's he gonna do
follow-up here has a good opportunity
again he does have a slight life lead
see what he does with it
and yeah he's fishing for that down for
two
tiny
that 3-2 is working man he's he's gotten
it to work quite a bit so far beautiful
he caught him so off-guard with that
relaxed approach
that dvk totally froze
take the trade all day
ran up and killed him here we go
the follow one round calum looking
really good obviously the open stage
definitely helping his game plan
oh that didn't hit
good block
superman yeah that superman punch home
has been working out actually it's been
a really good approach to get over the
size of four
oh my gosh stringing them how did you
miss i don't know
power get that power out i'll do enough
damn to kill you
here we go tied up on rounds this is big
because you know dbk if he's able to
take this match it's all over and callum
will be out of the tournament but calum
he's still moving with that confidence
that was sick
that was actually so sick he he let dbk
think that they were playing a close
range game when he was like i'm going to
slow back dash away here boom boom
it's all about creating that space up
close because you know it's one thing to
go back but it's another thing to go
back and then wait for the whiff punish
oh what is going on
tbk
don't drop it like this oh good block
he's gonna be is he dead i think he's
dead i think he is
no
that didn't hit usually it's guaranteed
trying to clutch it out
good stuff good stuff from calum round
four that's a long leg
standing four able to close it out here
calum looking for an opportunity he
caught him ducking there he flashed like
14 times i love that calvin did that
right just to see what he would do make
him think about it yeah
man i would while standing one three all
day if that's all he did to me
just that little low kick that's it yeah
that's all i'll do i'm down
he's fishing
oh the lows are coming out you know he
blocks that he might get that nice
punish though
dbk has to be careful here
try to catch him
time's a waste in
nice nice
he's got he's had so much trouble
approaching this this game dvk has
yeah he finally got him to break but
right when he did he hit that counter
hit down forward too
he's gonna have to be careful again
because right now he's approaching
callum might do it again
in nine seconds rage mode drive spend
post to keep out he's gonna backdash all
day oh look at that we're going to a
final match
we're going to a final match of course
we are callum likes to keep things
interesting like this dude
we saw a set earlier with big daddy mike
that went down to the wire now this one
going down as well final game incoming
here
anyone's game to be honest i think you
know that game obviously dk had a much
harder time getting in uh you know cal
did a much better job of playing the
keep out game uh the down four twos were
there you know the size of fours are
there uh the slow back dash i really
liked uh early which i talked about
right slow back dash let him whip and
get the mirage for the whiff punish like
that's i think optimum letting play when
you're getting the mirage whiff punish
on everybody that's when you really make
it impair right you're taking off like
35 40 instead of just like little pokes
every time uh so we'll see if you can
keep that going but dbk we're not he's
got to find a way in he like he did a
good job of that in game three but
obviously game four the keep out game
was better so this has been really back
and forth you know the counter play is
coming through which is exactly we saw
earlier from calum so this is really
cool
all right so we're going to another
pivotal match this is important for all
the marbles
one of these two players will move on
one will be out of the tournament in
third place
any any thoughts here i'm not going to
ask who your favorite is but do who do
you think i mean based on the momentum
and what we've seen so far
any thoughts on on what's going to
happen in the match with dv dbk's kind
of been
letting it go
i think he's questioning himself the
thing is it's been very back and forth
the whole way oh yeah i feel like
you know either callum's figured it out
now download's complete or
dbk's gonna make bring this back and
calm's not gonna give up and then we're
gonna final final round so it's either
gonna be like a beat down or final final
round that's my call
here we go
this is where it's all gonna go down
oh yeah the last match between these two
and i feel like
again sometimes when you play these
longer sets
there's going to be some wear like
you're going to eventually
kind of break i mean it gets frustrating
i mean if you're chasing eddie the
entire time and that's kind of what
happened in the last match you're going
to get frustrated and you're going to
start playing differently
so calum actually kind of betting oh my
god he caught him with the relaxed
double relax in his face and caught him
looking that's one of the callum
specials man and the upward four they're
working out rage mode now dbk do you
have anything no sir ghost from the
downford one two
calum solid life lead there close that
round one
yeah that was strong there's a follow-up
again man i would do that all day
running three this time callum is
playing offensively he's trying to
really throw off dvk
it's working he is actually attacking
but a big counter hit there from dbk
[Music]
uh-huh
let's see what he does here
oh that's that could have been doesn't
matter
nice that 442 able to close things out
one round a piece here again
you guys are going back and forth
it's gonna happen
you think so yep the ffr is gonna happen
you know it
man i don't know if it's jinxing or
blessing
it's always a blessing for us viewing it
he caught him ducking
then down three to three
able to get that launch here and pushing
at the wall no launch punch at all
punishable he got nothing though like
not even anything
yeah he has to try he is at least
attempting because right now calum knows
that he can do that he's going to get
away with it
oh and a big punish
this is unfortunate for dbk he let that
one go he could have taken that momentum
even further and just like that calum
one round away from moving on to grand
finals
again
i'm scared man it might be a mid
lava toes
lava toast yeah we gotta watch out
there's lava
oh
calories
we both have light colored pants can we
come to a truce
right now the only truce oh wait
look at all callum right now dvk trying
to approach tournament life on the line
here he's enraged
the drive he got him this is this is big
because it could be a lot of damage
let's see what he ends up finishing it
with what's the mix boy howdy back there
said that was crazy i don't know i don't
know i'm not big
where was it
oh but he got him trying to come in
again calum holds on
and eliminates dvk from the tournament
three to two nicely done nicely done
congratulations to both of you but of
course that means calum will be
advancing to the grand finals and we
have a rematch of our winner semis from
earlier today it's going to be
uh big daddy mike versus callum and i'm
excited to see that because they had a
crazy set early on definitely
definitely let's take a look back at
some of the action from this last
matches though uh this was definitely a
good set right you know you have first
of three and it goes down five games
it's always a good match but here we go
back to the very beginning that was such
a good hop kick from dvk got him with
ryan's face and boom that was the start
dvk on the board first
then as things are tied up here we go
into game number three down to the wired
throw break i don't think so but down
for one two stick with the downward ones
right he kept it close
yeah calum immediately goes back to
infinite stage after that uh which
seemed to be the answer and that was so
beautiful right the slow back dash there
got him whiff got some rocks with whiff
punish
he's done that throughout like the
entire tournament day his ability to
back dash and use that down three that
four three plus four it's just
impeccable but it really added up
because look i mean look at it dvk was
up two to one at one point looking like
he would take that that third match but
again it was all thanks to that
defensive prowess and then switching it
up out of nowhere in that final match
where he just went full on offense and
it ended up paying off big time i mean
he he had him so shook that he was
playing defensively early on that he was
able to just go in to relax and go for
slippery kicks and it worked yeah double
relax right relax stand up relax again
now i got you
that's one of the callum specials and
it's working for sure
oh yeah and of course you guys can see
all the events that we have going on
right now we are at region number seven
uh for south africa tomorrow we actually
have another event that's gonna be on
this very channel for the middle east
and then following up with the rest of
the events throughout uh the the next
few weeks leading up until early october
at that point we are going to switch to
our regional final events and we're
starting off with south africa and
that's in early november and all these
events are going to be happening almost
weekly leading up until early 2022 where
we finalize all of the regional events
and end it with north america
yeah gonna be crazy stuff guys make sure
you guys are registered at the website
so you guys can get yourself on these
leaderboards right this way you can find
all your dojo events and see where your
current standings are compared to all
the other players
uh and of course guys if you guys are
tournament organizers and you guys are
trying to register your events make sure
you guys submit that application soon
because the deadline is going to be
october 10th so not a lot of time left
before you guys can do that so get on
that submit your application get
approved get your players into some dojo
points oh yeah
of course you guys can follow us on all
of our channels whether it's on twitch
twitter facebook or youtube uh follow us
on bandai namco esports
on twitter we post a lot of clips from
the events and also some highlights and
then you can check out all of the events
and the archives on our youtube page as
well but again if you guys are watching
twitch.tv such tekken or on twitter or
through i mean even xbox is tuned in
right now so again whether whatever
platform you're watching on thanks guys
for tuning in with us and we are about
to get started with of course the grand
finals that we are all waiting for this
is going to be a revenge match from what
we saw earlier today so i hope you guys
are looking forward to it
exactly revenge match but before we get
there we do have some more shirts for
you guys good ass tekken these are
re-releases right we had the king and
the llama that came out earlier uh this
year very beginning of 2021 actually but
now they are back limited time back in
stock uh make sure you guys grab one if
you're interested
same website as last time 10-0 gg slash
merch or you guys could take a
screenshot get that qr code and access
the store that way but limited time guys
uh if you guys are one of those smaller
sizes like a medium or something you
already know what the deal is you got to
get in there soon otherwise it's going
to be gone yeah it'll be all gone and
again there's a lot of cool shirts make
sure you guys take advantage of it i'm
actually wearing the paul shirt right
now damn so if you guys that's also
available on the website i got this
shirt i don't know if this one's still
being sold out there you know it's uh it
might be it might go back in stock but
shout out to lord harada that's an
awesome shirt too but guys i hope you
guys are enjoying we are about to get
into our grand finals any any thoughts
here man this is gonna be exciting i
can't wait to see this again
uh big daddy mike has really been
flexing so far with what he's i mean
he's been playing with so much
confidence too you could see the way
that he was playing as brian throughout
the winter side action that we saw
earlier today but he's going to be going
up against the guy that took him to the
very limits they went down to the final
exchange of the match
in callum so i'm excited to see how this
works out yeah if you guys are just
tuning in now let me tell you the first
step between these guys and the top of
the top eight this was crazy it was back
and forth the whole way through five
round three one way five round straight
the other way then it goes down the
final final round and now we get the run
back right obviously big daddy mike took
the first set
coming back from the loser bracket this
time duomo de sirio to kick things off
this is the grand finals of the tekken
online challenge for the south africa
region oh yeah
callum from south africa versus big
daddy mike from mozambique this is our
grand finals it's gonna be a race to
three however if callum wants to win the
entire tournament he has to win two sets
but first things first let's see what
happens this opening set as we start
things off
boom relaxed no no punish
yeah maybe too relaxed maybe too relaxed
there i like it the back ones they're
doing work
they're forcing a reaction here out of
calamity
it seems well it seems like he's jabbing
that's the thing that he's doing to kind
of get out of that
i like what i'm seeing here
yeah that was instant adaptation he's
been watching right he's taking notes oh
that sucks goes to the throw
he still has good positioning though
let's see what big daddy mike's able to
do here
there's a life slight life deficit
between the two but nothing too
worrisome but this is big it's not gonna
kill sidewall messes things up
[Music]
and that's actually one of the the
stories from the first episode right
there was a lot of hatchet kicks
a lot of hats kicks that got hit uh if
callum had been blocking the lots of
those that would have been a very
different set yeah this time the
immediate block and lot's huge yeah he
might have been the one waiting in grand
finals had it been different either way
we're going right into this he's going
to push him towards the wall let's see
what the wall combo is this time
he wants the time oh yeah he really
wants it man he really wants to be the
crowd pleaser
all brian players do right
yeah i mean even if they can't do it
they'll go for it hell yeah just like
that
there was that one random tournament
that you played in and you ended up
getting brian and you did it
orbital over the drive let's go
fight yeah that's kind of crazy
boom nothing
yeah i mean look at this exchange nice
gets to follow oh i thought he did it
that was sick he you could tell he
tested him there he that down back to
not guaranteed after taunt so he tested
them by my ducking
oh
round four
northern cross cross dude
that move is such a sick that's such a
sick move it is
oh here we go
gets to follow what's the side step
attack no goes for the down 35
[Music]
to the flow
see what he does here no duck on the
second it doesn't matter locked and
loaded not going to get the wall but
it's going to do decent damage let's see
what the mix-up is soccer kick and
hatchet we're going to follow another
one there's the launch though he might
be dead he might be dead
not so
big daddy mike the clutch factor bro
that has been the tail dude the clutch
factor end of the round situation big
daddy mike has had it all day long he's
doing something that no brian player
does he lands the rage drive it's so
crazy he's like two already today that's
a a lifetime record here we have a new
season high that's crazy
i'm kidding by the way guys i'm kidding
by the way i'm just i'm gonna hit the
rage drive
hit it i mean i guess it's a little bit
easier when they can't sidestep it right
yeah i mean this is timing on it right
in general like so many moments he's
found those openings uh and the clutch
block afterward right like i was like
low he he's like yeah it's love blocking
it no problem uh got the follow-up
afterward too
just crazy stuff and you know this is
what we expect from these two it's
always down the wire you can't really
predict what's gonna happen uh the big
difference in this set so far compared
to the first set callum is blocking the
hatchets and getting the full launchers
on them right yeah he's getting punished
even when he blocked it he wouldn't get
the launcher correctly i think he only
landed one correct punch on it in the
first set but this set already at least
three right but still didn't get in the
first game
in advocation of the devil i will play
devil's advocate here
maybe he wants him to block the low
maybe he wants to set him up for some
nasty stuff because brian has some
pretty devastating mids as well
but i feel like that's one way to do it
is if you can kind of train your enemy
to start
seeing those that are see not well you
can't really see it but starting to
block the the hatchet kicks right then
it kind of opens opens things up at
least a little bit more midwives maybe
we're gonna start seeing like sway into
orbital soccer kick a lot of others
yeah i mean that's like some next level
stuff right
but i mean again it all matters with uh
how you kind of do it because like
getting your low and blocked and kind of
launch punish is not the end of the
world it just means that hey they're
looking out for it now and sometimes
that's what you want that's that's what
you want because that means if they're
waiting for the low that means they're
not attacking that means they're waiting
true but i also feel like he's very
heavy on hatchet throughout like all the
opponents he's played against oh yeah oh
yeah for sure
right so i think it's just what he wants
like obviously he can mix it up uh i
want to see that i want to see where
layer two and where layer three is let
me let me see that i think i think we're
gonna see it by the end of the set
because right now there's been a lot of
good blocks on it a lot of big damage
out of it the problem is he still lost
the game right like despite getting all
those blocks and full launches on the
hatchets he still lost that first game
so that's got to be a little bit
demoralizing i think because i did feel
like that was one of the big differences
in that first set that was so close
between them yeah
definitely definitely but again we this
is just the beginning it was only the
first game we have potentially two sets
here let's see let's see of course if
callum is able to kind of fight back
which he did in in the past you know
so he could go dvk
yeah i mean i mean he's he's been
stretching it out quite a bit for all of
the matches that we've seen him play
actually now that you mention it so
ability to fight and the ability to just
that's that's really what it comes down
to especially in short sets and of
course a little bit longer but we'll see
how this plays out of course but not the
you know going into this you know
without really knowing too much about
the players in south africa did not
expect to see
uh eddie and brian uh here i i was
thinking like we'd see some bob we'd see
some lars which we did see a lot of lars
by the way
bob dude
bob is like
bob's crazy now i
i don't see enough bob i feel like there
should be more bob out there
bob is crazy
anyways we're gonna go back into the
matchup it's precipice of fate
and it's callum again
sticking to eddie
uh and he's great with this character
right uh oh yeah see if we put them
together here though
every time i see this intro and i see
the tree move i'm like does that tree
really move yeah
i don't know it does it does in this in
this this uh fly over here
it is moving man can you brian brian and
eddie can you guys get out of the way
i'm trying to look at the background let
me see these trees man change
chains chains chains are you serious i
mean that was one of the weaknesses we
noticed right no throw breaks from calum
not as many
yeah
and that's the thing brian only has
uh other than normal throws he only has
one plus two throw brakes
but i thing if somebody's not breaking
through then you can just start getting
away with the regular throw too oh yeah
like that is the mix of the throw game
now in tekken 7 people can't break those
inside the oneplus 2 or not
yeah inside the unfortunate thing is
some some characters don't really have
that right yep like poor akuma doesn't
have a throat or a puma
for no one ever
he needs buffs bro yeah
give him a throw and oh he's poor
yeah four man said no one ever yeah
all right let's see what he does here
man he's uh he's waiting i don't know
what he's waiting for but he's waiting
for something big
different way
way too far
talent chilling backdashing all day i
like this approach though i mean
calum
and big daddy mike it's like they're
waiting they're they're building up
meter internal meter
waiting to explode yep damn explosion
it's called spirit
here we go
that way they can just let loose again
throws bro throws it's something that
we've seen already that those throws
have been working so much
drive
how did he land it
man nicely done calum the power is loose
yep
sometimes you just need that fighting
spirit
uh-huh there's the low the follow-up
what's gonna do again yo oh my gosh you
got impatient
yo things are getting different here for
calum i like it he tried to hit him with
that hot plate special to follow up here
let's see what he does
oh there you go and that's again how you
do it that's how you put the reaction
on reaction he's blocking him i believe
it round four
well he might get uh hit by soccer kick
on reaction next we'll see
because that's also on reaction
sometimes you get hit by by [ __ ] so hard
in the game you like reel backwards and
then you hit your head on the back of
your chair that's real that thing is
real that happens to you good luck all
the blessings sent your way
oh gotta catch him but he transitioned
into the fourth people sport here we go
that's an opportunity that down back to
it was close enough this should be the
wall not with that combo no sir taught
too far as well
i mean i feel like if he gets a taunt
jet upper i'm going to give him the
tournament yep straight up we'll just
stop things right there more back two
three
oh all right keeps them there
not dead taunt
fakie heel flip for the win
let's get it big daddy mike
trying to go up 2-0 here
he's fishing
see what he does
dude these guys are playing so compact
yet going crazy at the same time i agree
he'll punier
the wall
late tech there
like what i'm seeing man you really
punch perry you know punch perry eddie
gordo like that is it that serious
that's the one he needed he's mine mind
boggled up boggled
boots
oh my gosh unfortunate
hey big daddy is one match away from
winning the entire tournament rip
yeah he is uh and that that wall balance
was so crucial right like the angle was
good where he was away from the wall off
it a little bit it wasn't like right
there at the wall so that was just a
huge drop huge i like i like what we're
seeing here this brian fury
a big daddy is redeeming the big daddy
name after it's been soiled in the past
he's bringing it back
yeah you forgot about him i never forgot
i don't forgot like what's wrong with
diesel big daddy cool was one of the
choo choo
no thank you everyone for watching on
the official channels i appreciate it
and the official youtube anyways we're
gonna go into what could be the final
match of the tournament i'm excited for
it
definitely and you know when you really
look back at the last round of that
final game those two back-to-back huge
mistakes from callum right he blocked
the hatchet and went for while standing
too he didn't even do the while standing
on one four like he's been doing right i
mean he had that opportunity and he's
just like dude that was like the one
time in this set that he really failed
to punish it and then immediately after
that lands the wall bounce
and doesn't really follow up with the
screw attack or combo you know so
maybe it was just unexpected because i
mean how often does that land for eddie
because you know it's one of the it's
one of the slowest and why did you do it
and it hit it you know
i don't know man let's ask him
it's just unfortunate but here we go 2-0
lead for being oh
mike
needs one more
he fell into his trap this is what he
wanted the whole time
he be infinite or sure you want it you
know remember once he picks infinity he
gets that crazy power up
he gets that crazy power up
let's see what he does anyways this
good callum every time he lost he didn't
pick it last night because obviously we
had walls right but this time he did
pick it he was saving up that spirit we
were talking about all right oh my gosh
he's locked breaker through his spirit
he's dead he's broken
the spurs running low
it's running low
got a refill
uh-huh
add some fuel to the fire
what it's an electric car oh my god
we're dead
pixels
all right big daddy feeling obviously
hey yo mikey
let's go cal never given up
i'm never gonna get tired of seeing that
seeing that downpour three plus four
launch is so cool
[Music]
oh really you're gonna go for that big
drop kick there
[Music]
well oh he's gonna have to be careful
okay
[Music]
he does have the life lead so calum
let's see how he kind of deals with it
he will punish the orbital that's easier
said than done
easier said than done
very very nicely done there calvin all
right
round count tied game three
calum definitely
focused in you know he's got that gamer
lean going on right now
sitting the chair leaning forward front
half of the seat face closer to the
monitor
[Music]
oh there's the hatchet this is how it
starts those hats oh this could be big
oh
the falls
i just got quiet afterwards like where's
the jedi
oh man
life's pretty close here
good jab keep out
he's testing him
ended with the high version
oh
he's in rage
how is he going to deal with it
you can't relax
against the galaxy the orbital is too
strong
here we go daddy mike
tournament point
mirage is good
calum not out of it yet
[Music]
good combo lots of life there
you know those hatchets are coming out
he's gonna chop away
you're gonna hit him with that chief
thunder
see what he does
good option
oh he jabbed it
uh-huh wow got him nice down back dude
that was smart yeah he wanted to get the
orbital there but here we go final round
still tournament point for big daddy
mike could close it out with the 3-0
here
trying to stay alive in the tournament
big chance here big opportunity right
now big daddy mike is he going to change
things up how is he going to approach
here calum right now going with the down
forward too he's going to have the life
lead is he going to run or he's going to
continue the pressure that's the
question pressure
pressure to counter it
has been the answer
nice oh there's the launch he's going to
put him into range as well let's see
what he does with it last time oh yes
it's the running three low that is
something that we have not seen much out
of calum at all and you know i had
flashbacks at first that as soon as he
tapped into rages like three hits and he
was dead right two hits so i was scared
for a moment but callum staying alive it
will not be asleep
it might be a reset after this that's
how when these days i feel like that's
you only needed one man win one match
you get a reset that's crazy i don't
know it might be a reset guys i'm just
saying you know
anything could happen here but calum
definitely looked good there the
downpour two as soon as he hit the
counter down for two i was like this is
what's been missing in this set so far
right uh so and then he immediately
followed instant running three uh these
are options he hasn't really gone to in
this set so really nice to see calum
bringing out everything
because you need to right it's it's
grand finals you know you go home he he
finally got the call the wake up call
right this is what he needed and again
hopefully it's it's that you know a
little boost that he needs to really get
back into the match because again it's
nowhere close to being over he needs to
win two more matches still
right he needs to win two more matches
and my thoughts here is you know as you
go into this big daddy mike has the
option to pick the stage right
he's probably gonna go for something
that can restrict eddie's movement i
wouldn't be surprised if we saw like a
suit or mashima dojo out of them right
the walls obviously will benefit will
benefit him overall but anyways either
way we're going to find out as we go
into this matchup
what's going to happen because it's all
coming down to this he might be so
carefree oh he he picked the jimmy j
tran stage
oh he wants damage best music there are
two
two breakable walls here that could lead
to a ton of damage it actually really
benefits combo wise
um brian fury this is a really good
stage for him
anyways
get to the choppa
get to the choppa
here we go another potent final game and
you know
if your big daddy mike here and you you
knew how close that was to winning
sometimes that plays mind games on you
let's see if you can stay focused here
he's had the clutch back to end the
rounds usually
oh yeah
go ahead daddy
oh
let's go oh here we go he's gonna push
towards the wall all right i would like
to go i would like to see him go for
down three two after blocking that
especially when he's near the wall
down down forward too and that was right
after big daddy mike did not punish
earlier too by the way
geez look at the combo trying to catch
him again
oh oh bad trade what no counter no
counter in yo someone got robbed
how did that not what the hell
i'm so confused
nice
call him call him and let him know
i'm continuing his his his momentum from
the last match getting another round
looking to tie things up here
uh-huh nice pickup there it is you try
to transition into something the
follow-up he has the wall
no tech rolls
damn that's the strats
if he's gonna stay on the floor he's not
tech rolling go for it
i love that option
orbital's been killing him yep it's fine
not much damage
those back ones they're going to add up
but he has to watch out those back ones
even though it does help him provide
some pressure he has to watch out for
the jab and the down forward too
spring
all right interesting interesting
tying it up on rounds here
that's another number four
of five
important
he still got it
done oh my god okay that was close to
these guys
oh my gosh that's guaranteed too that's
a that's a true combo
time down back one plus two here we go
orbital break them
break a breaker
to the wall and you're dead
tournament point big daddy mike
fight
can he do it we'll call him oh my gosh
that could have been a launch too
oh what are you going to do
galaxy's favorite the orbital heel
here's your chance han
[Music]
no perfect
yes
wall's in the way
oh sidewalks are messing up
oh
big daddy mike over calum
and big daddy mike is the tekken online
challenge 2021 south african region
champion congratulations big daddy mike
nice to meet you gotta give it up well
represented mozambique ends up winning
the south african regional tournament
the master event here and of course he
is going to be the big points leader now
here in the region pretty much guarantee
i want to say pretty much guaranteeing
him a spot in the regional finals for
sure great stuff nonetheless good stuff
yeah and grace left the callum as well
right very entertaining matches
throughout the day uh obviously his
first big daddy mike was ridiculous
probably still my favorite set of the
day oh yeah another crazy run back in
the loser final as well uh so great
stuff to count throughout the entire day
uh let's take a look see here back at
some of the action we just had uh and
you know it was really as expected a
little bit back and forth there but
clutch rage drives man and what a clutch
finish that was in the first game even
oh yeah and look at that just following
it up here looking to kind of run away
with it he gets the big follow-up but he
had his chance there and that could have
been much different but again 2-0 big
daddy mike again switching over to the
infinity jordan this is something that
worked out for callum so much throughout
the tournament but hey slow and steady
wins the race
looking to come back did he have enough
spirit he had a chance here he had a big
chance and he was able to kind of
capitalize off it into the instant
running three but this takes us to our
final match and of course we know how
this ended up we just saw it
yeah right to the wall big lead big
damage that's why he wanted the stage
that's the reason he picked it and then
just a little bit too far away perfect
pick up from big daddy mike and that
will be that he is the champion here
today uh congratulations once again big
daddy mike technolon child 2021 south
african region champion
and i got to give it up everybody that's
tuned in throughout the entire day you
guys can see the bracket and how we
progress throughout here we saw a lot of
the talent here from the south africa
region so many different uh regions and
countries are sorry countries within the
region represented here on top we have
south africa mozambique kenya zambia and
madagascar so again thank you for
everybody that participated close to 90
people
entering this tournament and we're going
to see more from this in the last that
we're seeing from south africa in early
november of course we do have our
regional final and as you guys can see
the new standings here for south africa
big daddy mike
in a very convincing first place at 300
points
exactly these are the players that we
will be seeing back here uh in the
regional finals right that'll be in uh
november i believe november 6th but i
mean for this region there's still time
they can still get points through the
dojo events so check out some of these
guys yeah i think for a lot of the guys
especially if they're bigger tournaments
they're gonna have to be very very
careful especially if you're in the
fifth or seventh place kind of tied in
in that points range but for the other
four guys at the top four i think
they're pretty good i'd be i'd be
comfortable if i was in that position
yeah big chilling indeed
man what about what a fun day dude like
i mean obviously we talked about earlier
but shout outs to bandai namco
entertainment for hosting these tekken
online challenge events around the world
you know all these new regions that we
haven't gotten to see you know on this
sort of a stage before i think that's
really awesome uh really cool to see the
south african players oh yeah
of course i gotta just because i always
love them the astro gaming team got to
give a big shout out to them the
official headset and mcsamp of the
tekken online challenge again supporting
uh the technology challenge the tech and
community just fighting game community
in general lots of love to them for
always supporting what we do and what we
love but again i gotta also give a lot
of shout outs to everybody that tuned in
and watched throughout the day
especially if you're from our region
in north america i know it's a very
early day for you but thank you for
spending some of your weekend with us
but
but
that is not it you guys can follow us
for more information check us out on
twitter on beginning esports where
you'll be getting updates because there
is another event that's happening
tomorrow and this time it'll be still on
twitch.tv second about focusing on the
middle east so i hope you guys are ready
for that because there is more tekken of
course this weekend next weekend and
following weekends to come but again you
guys can follow us on all those
different accounts that you guys see on
the screen right now
all right
and i do believe that's gonna do it for
us here today mark uh the tekken online
challenge
21. uh thank you again once once again
to everyone who joined us shades are
coming off is that is that the signal is
that the we're going home folks we're
going home i almost threw them but if i
threw them i might not be able to get
them back
but either way it's been fun rip
anything you want to say to the tech
fans that are tuned in and watching
still nah man just shout out to the
south african community for coming
through today obviously we had almost 90
entries for the tournament that's huge
you know hopefully that more regions
around the world will be included in
this next time around because i know
there's always anytime that things like
this expand your reasons not involved it
was like what about my region you know
post up on twitter let us know show us
your scene and hopefully you guys can be
involved next time
yep shout outs to the 10-0 crew again uh
buy a shirt if you guys can check out
the 10-0 gg
merch site for all the tech insurance
that we saw earlier today and again just
again please keep enjoying tech and we
have more stuff that's going to be
coming tomorrow and throughout other
weekends in the future but until then
for rip and for myself mark guys thanks
again for tuning in and we will see you
next time peace out
so
[Music]
you
[Music]
first
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
you